Hello, good morning, or good afternoon, or evening, whatever it is, I'm Jason. The guy interrupting and mumbling is Will, and it looks like Sean Hayes. I'm over here. There he is. Hi. Did you just take nappies? Yeah. I hope our listeners are still awake, because this is smartless.
大家好，早安、午安，或者晚安，隨便啦，我是傑森。那個打斷別人又咕噥的人是威爾，看起來還有西恩·海斯。我這邊也有。他來了。嗨。你們剛剛是不是小睡了一下？對啊。我希望我們的聽眾都還醒著，因為這是《SmartLess》。
Here it comes. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless. It means so much to me, like a birthday, you're a pretty view. Sorry, I just wanted to say that lyric. I had to get that out.
來了。聰明。聰明。聰明。聰明。這對我意義重大，就像生日一樣，你真是一處美麗的風景。抱歉，我只是想說那句歌詞。我必須把它說出來。
OCD style. Go ahead. Where did the new love for Duran Duran come from? I love Duran Duran. Archie or Abel? No. you've always talked about or done. What's far-fetched?
強迫症風格。請繼續。對杜蘭杜蘭的新熱情是從哪裡來的？我愛杜蘭杜蘭。亞契還是阿貝爾？不。你一直談論或做過的事。什麼是無稽之談？
First of all, Shawn, you know the restaurant, Jones on Third, what do I do all the time? Anytime somebody mentions it, I go, Jones on Third, two minutes later. Duran Duran is always here, man. It's always, it's right, it's a click away. It's right on my desktop, okay? But why not Pet Shop Boys or Wham or ABC?
首先，西恩，你知道那家餐廳，瓊斯第三分店，我常常做什麼？只要有人提起它，我就會說，瓊斯第三分店，兩分鐘後。杜蘭杜蘭一直都在，老兄。它一直都在，就在點擊之間。它就在我的桌面上，好嗎？但為什麼不是寵物店男孩、威猛樂隊或ABC樂隊？
Why not, you know, why not anything, Jason? Why not anything? Did you have like a really special experience at a Duran Duran concert and that's what's, you know, really entrenched it for you? It was the soundtrack of my youth. Did you buy the albums, Duran Duran album? Of course I did.
為什麼不，你知道的，為什麼不什麼都行，傑森？為什麼不什麼都行？你在杜蘭杜蘭的演唱會有過什麼特別的經歷，然後這才成為，你知道的，真正讓你深陷其中的原因嗎？那是我的青春配樂。你有買過他們的專輯，杜蘭杜蘭的專輯嗎？我當然買過。
Okay, shh. Why am I shushing? Why are you shushing me? Because do you know this commercial with that use of the Pet Shop Boys, because Jason brought up Pet Shop Boys, where it's like, I got the brains. You got the bra, let's relax a little bit.
好了，噓。我為什麼在噓？你為什麼噓我？因為你知道那個用寵物店男孩歌曲的廣告嗎？因為傑森提到了寵物店男孩，裡面大概是這樣的：我有頭腦。你有胸部，我們稍微放鬆一下。
Oh yeah, that guy driving in the car. That guy just driving, and then the head ornament sings, and I don't understand, I don't get it. I don't either. Actually, you know what, I think that guy's got a good voice. It's sure, no, everybody involved is wonderful. I just don't get the product and the song,
哦對，那個開車的傢伙。那個傢伙只是開車，然後頭部裝飾唱了起來，我不明白，我搞不懂。我也不懂。其實，你知道嗎，我覺得那傢伙嗓音不錯。確實，不，每個人都很棒。我只是搞不懂那個產品和這首歌，
and I don't know what's happening. I don't either, it's effective though. We're talking about it right now, but we don't know the product. Because here I got, here I'm sitting with a couple of Hollywood insiders who are out of touch with what the rest of us. Elite Hollywood insiders.
而且我不知道發生了什麼。我也不知道，不過挺有效果的。我們現在在談論它，但我們不知道那是麼產品。因為我在這裡，我在這裡跟幾個跟不上我們其他人節奏的好萊塢內部人士坐在一起。好萊塢菁英內部人士。
Sorry, I forget, I forget, right. Sorry, you're right, you're absolutely right. I stand corrected, Hollywood Elite Insiders. Thank you. And I, I'm Joe, I'm like Tracy, and Shawn's sister and I are very similar in a lot of ways. We're both normal, knock around people from the neighborhood.
抱歉，我忘了，我忘了，對。抱歉，你是對的，你絕對是對的。我收回前言，好萊塢菁英內部人士。謝謝。而我，我是喬，我有點像崔西，西恩的妹妹和我有很多相似之處。我們都是從社區出來的正常、隨和的人。
We've got a name on her now. Her name's Tracy. It's Tracy, it's always been Tracy, by the way. We've never referred to her by her name. Of course we have. I think Shawn just remembered it, actually. Jason, I'm now starting to understand. I'm now on a man decide in your,
我們現在給她取了個名字。她叫崔西。順便說一句，她一直叫崔西。我們從來沒有用名字叫過她。我們當然叫過。我覺得西恩其實是剛才才想起來的。傑森，我現在開始明白了。我現在要站在你這邊，
in your, in your lifetime battle, because you don't pay attention. She's right. Well, I'm constantly thinking about me. I don't have time to hear anything else. What did you, one time I said to you, this is at least almost 20 years ago, we were watching football and Amanda came in
在你那場，在你那場，在你一生中的戰鬥中，因為你都不注意聽。她說得對。好吧，我滿腦子都在想我自己。我沒時間聽別的。你呢，我有一次對你說過，這至少是快20年前的事了，我們在看球賽，亞曼達進來了，
and she was like giving you grief about something and I go, wow, that's a lot. And do you remember what you said to me? No. You said, I got her on a different channel. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, it's a different volume slider. It's usually down around one or two.
她好像在為某事跟你抱怨，然後我說，哇，這真不容易。你還記得你對我說過什麼嗎？不記得。你說，我把她轉到別的頻道了。對，對。對，那是不同的音量滑桿。通常調在1或2左右。
And by the way, and she knows, and she's like, oh God, but you know what, now I'm on Amanda's side. Cause you're not paying attention. It's always been Tracy. We've always said Tracy. I'm one of those guys that's probably gonna fake a hearing loss much, much earlier than it's actually happening.
順便說一句，她知道，她心想，噢天啊，但你知道嗎，現在我站在亞曼達這邊了。因為你根本沒注意聽。她一直叫崔西。我們一直都叫崔西。我大概是那種會比實際情況早很多時候就假裝聽力受損的人。
So I don't have to answer too many questions. I'm gonna give myself an hour. I may just have like a fake hearing aid for years. Oh man, what a great sentence, genius. Have you ever noticed, you've already got the dumb look on your face. I mean, that's built in. I go to anger a lot faster than I used to with age
這樣我就不用回答太多問題了。我要給自己一個小時。我可能好幾年都戴著假助聽器。天啊，多麼棒的一句話，天才。你有沒有發現，你臉上已經露出愚蠢的表情了。我的意思是，那是天生的。比起以前，我現在隨著年齡增長更容易生氣，
because yesterday I was upstairs looking out the window in the backyard. Staring out the window. Sitting in a chair. Staring out the window. Okay, granddad. Thinking about my actions in my future. And I looked up and I saw our dog eating poop again.
因為昨天我在樓上透過窗戶看著後院。盯著窗戶看。坐在椅子上。盯著窗戶看。好吧，爺爺。思考著我的行為和未來。我抬起頭，看到我們的狗又在吃大便了。
And I was so upset. I was so upset. I screamed down to Scotty. And I go, Scotty, Ricky's eating his poop again. And he goes outside. I go, no, inside at the dining room table with a nice glass of wine. Yeah, outside.
我超級沮喪。我超級沮喪。我朝著史考提大喊。我說，史考提，瑞奇又在吃他的大便了。他走到外面去。我說，不，在裡面的餐桌旁，喝著一杯美酒。對，在外面。
And he got so upset at me cause I came back so fast with such sarcasm. When you saw the dog in the backyard were you worried that it was gonna start digging up all the gold that you've buried everywhere in your backyard? Like a crazy old person. Were you worried about that?
他對我非常生氣，因為我反應太快，充滿了諷刺。當你看到狗在後院時，你會不會擔心牠會開始挖出你埋在後院各處的金子？像個瘋狂的老頭。你會擔心這個嗎？
But he's got that little sonar thing, don't you find it? Just in case. I gotta train him where it's the most disgusting thing in the world. Okay, so, you know, speaking of disgusting, well, not really, it's a terrible segue, but our guest today is a real catch, huh?
但他有那個小小聲納探測器，你不覺得嗎？以防萬一。我得訓練牠，這是世界上最噁心的事。好吧，你知道，說到噁心，好吧，其實不算，這是一個糟糕的過渡，但我們今天的嘉賓真是個寶，對吧？
Well, our guest is a real catch. First of all, our guest is incredible, talented, multi-talented in lots of different ways. Our guest is an artist, our guest is a writer, our guest is a performer, our guest is all those things. I once said to our guest, I've seen you on the beach and I've seen you on TV, two of a billion stars that mean so much to me.
我們的嘉賓真是個寶。首先，我們的嘉賓非常了不起，很有才華，在許多不同方面都多才多藝。我們的嘉賓是一位藝術家，我們的嘉賓是一位作家，我們的嘉賓是一位表演者，我們的嘉賓就是這些。我曾對我們的嘉賓說過，我在海灘上見過你，我也在電視上見過你，億萬繁星中的兩顆，對我意義重大。
Like a birthday or a pretty view, but then I'm sure that you know it's just for you. It's not real. Our guest is Justin Thoreau. Oh! Hi. Oh my God. It's sweet Lord, look at you. He's in disguise too.
就像生日或美麗的風景，但我確信你知道這只屬於你。這不是真的。我們的嘉賓是賈斯汀·瑟魯。哦！嗨。哦天啊。親愛的上帝，看看你。他也喬裝打扮了。
Wow. Are you in disguise? It's a really aggressive reveal. Yeah. And it only works, it's great for podcast. You look like Bobby Valentine when he was trying to pretend he was not on the, Bobby Valentine on the Mets bench. That's a reference to not everybody's gonna get.
哇。你有變裝嗎？這是一個非常高調的亮相。對。而且這招只有在播客裡才有效。你看起來像巴比·瓦倫丁，當他試圖假裝自己不在大都會隊休息區的時候，巴比·瓦倫丁。這是一個不是每個人都懂的梗。
Listen, our Justin has a, about a 40 pound mustache on his upper lip and he's about to tell us why. 40 pounds, yeah. I just started a new job. So the beard had to go and we left him a stash. And what's the job? This is the Watergate thing, yeah? Yeah, Watergate, I mean G Gordon Liddy.
聽著，我們的賈斯汀上唇留著大約40磅重的小鬍子，他馬上要告訴我們原因。40磅，對。我剛開始一份新工作。所以鬍子不得不刮掉，而我們留下了這個小鬍子。這是什麼工作？這是水門案的那個，對吧？對，水門案，我是說G·戈登·利迪。
Oh, that's great. It's a film about Watergate or a play or? It's a limited series for HBO and with Woody Harrelson. And we were just about to start out, isn't it? What's that? Isn't it your brain, your brain baby a little bit? No, not at all. It was a totally different person's brain baby.
哦，太棒了。這是一部關於水門案的電影還是話劇？這是為HBO拍攝的限定劇，由伍迪·哈里遜主演。我們正要開始，對吧？什麼？這不是你的，這算是你的腦力結晶嗎？不，完全不是。這是完全屬於另一個人的腦力結晶。
It was something that happened. Brain baby is not an expression. Both of you stop using it. Exactly. Justin, I'm so, hang on a second. Justin, I'm so excited you're here. I mean, it's so good to see you, JP. Listener, this is a great answer
這是發生的事。「腦力結晶」不是這種說法。你們兩個都別再用了。沒錯。賈斯汀，我太，等一下。賈斯汀，很高興你來了。我是說，很高興見到你，JP。聽眾們，這對我腦海中長久以來的疑問來說，是一個很好的解答。
to a long-running question inside my head. Thank you, Tracy. Of which one of us was gonna bring you on the show? Yeah, it was a battle. And I can't believe it took this long. Well, I can't believe it took this long either. And I'm honored that it was Will and I'm disappointed it wasn't you.
謝謝你，崔西。到底是我們中的哪一個要邀請你上節目？對，這是一場爭奪戰。我真不敢相信花了這麼長時間。嗯，我也真不敢相信花了這麼長時間。我很榮幸邀請到你的是威爾，我也很遺憾不是你。
Yeah, well, we've been talking a lot about you. I don't know if you're aware. That's how I heard about the podcast. And I'm excited because I don't know you as well as these guys do. I know. So it's like we're meeting for the first time. You guys do know each other.
對，我們一直在談論你。我不知道你有沒有意識到。我是這樣聽說這個播客的。我很興奮，因為我不像這些傢伙那麼了解你。我知道。所以感覺就像我們是第一次見面。你們兩個確實認識彼此。
We've met before. I think I was trying to remember it. We had a dinner somewhere. I don't think you'd like each other. No, boy. Yeah, I don't think we have anything. You're both who have been united. What about, can we talk for a second?
我們以前見過面。我一直在努力回想。我們在哪裡吃過飯。我覺得你們互看不順眼。不，天啊。對，我覺得我們沒什麼共同點。你們兩個都聯合起來了。關於這個，我們能談一下嗎？
Listen, I know you can't see this, but I'm looking at a really gorgeous place behind you. That's not your apartment in New York. Is it? That's a different angle. No, this is a place I've taken up residence and upstate New York. Do the owners know that?
聽著，我知道你看不到這個，但我正看著你身後一個非常華麗的地方。那不是你在紐約的公寓。對吧？那是不同的角度。不，這是我在紐約上州占據的一個住處。那裡的房主知道嗎？
No, not yet. No, not yet. I know you're squatting. Good for you. Squatting. Squatters rights are so vigorous in New York state. You can walk into any house and just take it over. I live here now.
不，還不知道。不，還不知道。我知道你在佔屋。做得好。佔屋。紐約州的佔屋者權利太強大了。你可以走進任何房子直接佔據它。我現在住在這裡。
Basically. Wait, I want to hear more. So it's Watergate, but you didn't write it. No, I didn't write it. I'm serious. But now that you mentioned G. Gordon-Liddy, that is a great description of that mustache. It is the perfect G. Gordon-Liddy mustache.
基本上。等一下，我想聽更多。所以是水門案，但不是你寫的。不，不是我寫的。我是說真的。但既然你提到了G·戈登·利迪，這對那撇鬍子真是個絕妙的形容。這絕對是G·戈登·利迪的標準鬍子。
It's a G. Gordon-Liddy mustache. Are you going to shave your head too? I mean, it's a car accident. What's happening up there right now. Can we see it? That's a real kind of, it's all dyed black. That's pretty short, but you can, was it his shorter? No, it wasn't actually, because we're playing in 71.
這就是G·戈登·利迪的小鬍子。你也要把頭剃光嗎？我的意思是，那簡稱車禍現場。上面現在到底怎麼回事。我們能看看嗎？那是那種，全都染成黑色的。那挺短的，不過你可以，他的頭髮有那麼短嗎？不，其實沒有，因為我們演的是71年。
So he was kind of a little bit freer with his hair in the 60s. When did he have the full cue ball? Yeah, at what point was that? That was later on. Those are the Miami Vice days. Yeah, they are. Are we doing those days in the show? No, we are sticking just to the break-in.
所以他在60年代的髮型算是比較自由奔放的。他什麼時候開始變成完全的光頭？對，那是哪時候？那是後來的事了。那是《邁阿密風雲》的時期。沒錯，確實是。我們在節目裡會演到那個時期嗎？不，我們只專注於闖入案。
God damn, you look good with that short hair. You look really good. And the glasses that change with the light inside and out, those are part of the character or those just yours? No, these are mine just so I can see you. These are my readers. So I can, we're all wearing, except for Will's not wearing glasses.
天啊，你留短髮真好看。你真的很好看。還有那副會隨室內外光線變色的眼鏡，那是角色造型的一部分，還是本來就是你的？不，這些是我的，這樣我才能看見你。這是我的老花眼鏡。這樣我才能，我們都戴著，除了威爾沒戴眼鏡。
I know. We're all wearing Jason's glasses are so strong. You know what I do need though? I do need like our friend Jen, she's got those glasses that have sort of the stuff to read at the bottom and then the stuff to see far at the top. That's what these are.
我知道。我們都戴著，傑森的眼鏡度數好深。不過你知道我需要什麼嗎？我確實需要像我們朋友珍那種眼鏡，下面有閱讀用的部分，上面有看遠處的部分。這就是這種。
Oh my God. What's it called? Bifocals, you fucking. Oh, this is Planet Earth. Everything can be referenced through a Duran Duran song. By the way, Justin, where do you fall on Duran Duran? I love Duran Duran. Yeah, thank you.
哦天啊。那叫什麼？雙光眼鏡，你這個混蛋。哦，這是地球。任何事都能跟杜蘭杜蘭的歌扯上關係。順對了，賈斯汀，你對杜蘭杜蘭有什麼看法？我愛杜蘭杜蘭。耶，謝謝。
Thank you. Tremendous band. Now, JT, so. Check your Wikipedia page, Will, for your next question. I'm not gonna ask him about his question. I know he's from DC. I know his mom is Phyllis. I know that, you know,
謝謝。了不起的樂隊。現在，JT，所以。威爾，查一下你的維基百科頁面準備下一個問題。我不會問他關於他的問題。我知道他是從華盛頓特區來的。我知道他媽媽叫菲莉絲。我知道，
he's a graduate of Bennington College. I know. You see, I didn't even look. He's a genius. I didn't even look. And I know he's from the neighborhood. We used to live in the same neighborhood, the same knock around neighborhood.
他是本寧頓學院畢業的。我知道。你看，我甚至沒查。他是個天才。我甚至沒查。而且我知道他是社區的人。我們以前住在同一個社區，同一個隨和的社區。
We used to live in exactly the same neighborhood. I want to know, I want to know because you're a creature of the theater, like I am when I spend a lot of time in the theater. He loves the boards. You still love doing that? Does you prefer one over the other? Or do you like crave to read?
我們以前住在完全相同的社區。我想知道，我想知道，因為你跟我一樣是個劇場動物，當我在劇場花了很多時間的時候。他熱愛舞台。你現在還喜歡做這件事嗎？你比較喜歡其中哪一個？還是你渴望閱讀？
You know, I get a lot of, I get a lot of flack for saying that no one gives me any flack because I haven't said it. But here it comes. I don't love doing theater anymore. What? I just don't like it. We're gonna add a record scratch.
你知道，我因為說「沒有人給我壓力，因為我還沒說過」而挨了很多罵。但它來了。我不再熱愛劇場表演了。什麼？我就是不喜歡。我們要加個唱片刮擦的音效。
Yeah. Yeah. Don't worry, we'll add it in. No, but the, I mean, I just, I don't find it, it's fun for the first like week, like doing Williamstown or something like that I would do, but I'm sure, or maybe you haven't experienced this, but you can do a play
對。對，別擔心，我們會加進去的。不，但是，我的意思是，我只是覺得，前一個禮拜還挺好玩的，比如去威廉斯敦之類的地方表演我會願意，但我確信，或者可能你沒有經歷過這種事，你可以演一齣戲，
and then you get like a, like sort of a shrug of a review and then all of a sudden half your half house empties out and then you're doing it for the next three months. Tracy's given a big amen to this. I know. Well, Justin, how long did you do? You did a bunch of theater in New York over the years, I know, and you have extensive resume in that department.
然後得到一個不冷不熱的評論，緊接著突然之間你的一半觀眾都走光了，然後接下來的三個月你都得在這種情況下演出。崔西對此表示強烈的贊同。我知道。好吧，賈斯汀，你演了多久？我知道你多年來在紐約演過一堆劇場作品，而且你在那方面資歷豐富。
So you had the, what was the big one you did? Shopping and fucking was a big hit, right? Whoa, whoa, whoa, language. It was a, yeah, it was a small theater big hit. Small theater big hit, but you got a great review. Yeah. It's a good name for an autobiography. I was just gonna say.
所以你有，你演過哪一部大作？《購物與愛愛》是一部大熱門，對吧？哇，哇，哇，注意用詞。那是個，對，是個小劇場大熱門。小劇場大熱門，但你得到了很棒的評價。對。這名字很適合當自傳。我剛才就想說。
Was that a couple months run? What was it? I forget what that was. Was that a decent run? It was at the New York theater workshop. I don't know. I think we did it for three months. I can't remember.
那是演了幾個月？那是怎樣？我忘了那是多久。那算是一個不錯的檔期嗎?那是紐約劇院工作室。我不知道。我想我們演了三個月。我記不清了。
It was a great cast too, right? It was, yeah. Me, Jenny Dundas, Philip Seymour Hoffman, Torkle Campbell, a Canadian. So you don't like the fact that you have to, but you don't do musicals because plays are only like two, three months, right? Musicals.
那卡司也很棒，對吧？是的，有我、珍妮·鄧達斯、菲利普·西摩·霍夫曼、托爾爾·坎貝爾，還有個加拿大人。所以你不喜歡必須去，但你又不演音樂劇，因為話劇通常只有兩、三個月，對吧？音樂劇。
Shut up, Sean. Shut up. Shut up, Sean. Sometimes we just make each other laugh, Justin, and you're just gonna have to wait, okay? We love each other. That's why we're doing it. We're not doing it for the money or...
閉嘴，西恩。閉嘴。閉嘴，西恩。有時候我們就是會把彼此逗笑，賈斯汀，你只能等一下，好嗎？我們相親相愛。這就是我們在做這件事的原因。我們不是為了錢或者……
It's such an awful... You know, listener, Justin Thoreau is one of our best writers in Hollywood. Best of writers. But he is, he just can't find the time to fit it in because of all of his great acting opportunities too, right? So how do you... He's too handsome to write.
這真是個糟糕的……你知道嗎，聽眾朋友，賈斯汀·瑟魯是好萊塢最優秀的編劇之一。最優秀的編劇。但他就是，因為他所有的精彩表演機會，抽不出時間來寫作，對吧？所以你怎麼……他太帥了，沒空寫作。
He's too handsome to write. I got sort of heartbroken by it because you start writing something and then you can work for something on for, you know, a year, year and a half, and then it can either go onto a shelf or someone buys your property and then it gets sort of just not made.
他太帥了，沒空寫作。我為此有點心碎，因為你開始寫點東西，然後你可以為之工作，你知道的，一年、一年半，然後它可能會被擱置，或者有人買下了你的版權，然後它就只是石沉大海了。
So it's, when it's working, it's fabulous. When it's not working. Just again, people who don't know, you've written tons of great things. The two of the bigger ones is Tropic Thunder and Iron Man 2. Yeah, but Justin, like you, so you and I are roughly the same age.
所以，當它順利進行時，棒極了。當它不順利時。再次說明，對於不知情的人，你寫過無數優秀的作品。其中比較大的兩部是《開麥拉驚魂》和《鋼鐵人2》。對，但賈斯汀，就像你一樣，你和我年紀差不多。
I'm a little older than you, although you can't tell, but in the 90s, in the 90s, well, I'm not wearing glasses to cover my eyes, but in the 90s, in the 90s, just don't look at my neck. Don't look at my neck. Don't look at my neck. When you, that's what Hollywood is, just don't look at my neck.
我比你大一點，雖然看不出來，但在90年代，在90年代，好吧，我沒戴眼鏡遮住眼睛，但在90年代，在90年代，只是別看我的脖子。別看我的脖子。別看我的脖子。當你，這就是好萊塢，只要別看我的脖子。
That's the whole game. Don't look at my neck a lot. I'm creping. By the way, I'm going to start investing in turtlenecks. I'm going to open a turtleneck store in Beverly Hills and I'm going to kill it. Only Richard Ehrlich can wear a turtleneck. You should sport a Dickie.
這就是整個遊戲規則。別太常看我的脖子。我皮膚鬆弛了。順便說一句，我要開始投資高領毛衣了。我要在比佛利山莊開一家高領毛衣店，然後大賺一筆。只有理查·埃利希才能穿高領毛衣。你應該穿一件假領。
I should. Richard Ehrlich gets a shout out on the podcast. God, we love Richard Ehrlich. So there we go. But you were in the 90s. I remember we didn't really know each other back then, but I'd see your name on sign-in sheets and audition and I'd kind of see you around.
我應該的。理查·埃利希在播客裡被大肆稱讚了。天啊，我們愛理查·埃利希。所以就是這樣。但你在90年代。我記得我們當時並不是很熟，但我會在簽到表和試鏡名單上看到你的名字，我也會常看到你。
You were a guy who was getting, who's doing a lot of stuff. You were doing, again, I brought up shopping and fucking, that was a great production that everybody was very cool and it was you and Phil Hoffman and a bunch, Jenny Dundas and a bunch of cool people. But what was that switch when you started, when writing became, there was a moment there
你當時是一個接了很多工作的傢伙。你當時正在，再次提到，我提到了《購物與愛愛》，那是一部非常酷的製作，每個人都很酷，裡面有你、菲爾·霍夫曼和一堆人，珍妮·鄧達斯和一堆很酷的人。但當你開始，當寫作變成，那裡有一個時刻，
for a couple of years where you really prioritized writing. Was that a conscious decision? How did that switch kind of happen? No, it's like everything else in my stupid career. I just, it was kind of tripping upstairs. It was Ben Stiller, I was doing a play actually on Broadway and Ben Stiller's then girlfriend was in it. And I was a big Ben Stiller nerd for the Ben Stiller show,
有那麼幾年你真的把寫作放在第一位，那是個有意識的決定嗎？這個轉變是怎麼發生的？不，就像我愚蠢職業生涯中的所有事情一樣。我只是，就有點像在樓梯上絆倒了。那是班·史提勒，我當時其實正在百老匯演一齣戲，班·史提勒當時的女友也在裡面。我是《班·史提勒秀》的超級書呆子，
which was a show that was recently on Fox and got canceled, but it was a big cult with Bob Odenkirk and everybody. Anyway, and I loved that show. And then I sort of, when he came backstage, I started sort of doing the show back to him like you do when you're a fan or something like that. And then we became friends.
那是一個最近在福斯電視台播出但被取消的節目，但它在鮑勃·奧登科克和其他所有人的推動下擁有極高的小眾崇拜。不管怎樣，我超愛那個節目。然後當他來到後台時，我就開始對他表演那個節目的橋段，就像你當粉絲或類似情況時會做的那樣。然後我們就成了朋友。
And then I started sort of writing kind of, or helping him or working with him and sort of punching up his appearances on Letterman or Conan and stuff like that. And then he was really like, you should write, you should actually write something. And so basically he had a rough pitch for Tropic Thunder. And he said, what do you think of this idea?
然後我開始寫點東西，或者幫忙他，或者和他一起工作，幫他潤飾他在萊特曼或柯南節目的亮相之類的。然後他真的對我說，你應該寫作，你真的應該寫點東西。基本上他對《開麥拉驚魂》有一個粗略的構想。他說，你覺得這個點子怎麼樣？
And we basically just, for a couple of years, just batted it back and forth on email, just making each other laugh. And then that was really kind of the first thing I wrote. That's amazing. Amazing. That movie's so good. But it was luck.
然後我們基本上就是這樣，花了好幾年透過電子郵件把這個點子拋來拋去，互相逗笑。然後那真的是我寫的第一個東西。太神奇了。太神奇了。那部電影太棒了。但那是運氣。
I mean, it was also him kind of, he's an incredible writer and he is incredibly good at sort of, you know, knowing the language of comedy and how it works, you know, and structure. He's really good at structure as well. So it was sort of like getting a PhD in comedy from Ben Stiller. But it was very kind of him to encourage me to do it.
我的意思是，這也是因為他，他是一個不可思議的作家，他非常擅長，你知道的，了解喜劇的語言及其運作方式，還有結構。他對結構也非常擅長。所以這有點像從班·史提勒那裡獲得喜劇博士學位。但他鼓勵我去做這件事，真的非常感謝他。
Justin, I was enjoying your, was it Esquire cover right now with you and the dog on the front? Thanks. I got the magazine, right? Yes? When you said you were enjoying it, what does that mean? Well, don't worry about that.
賈斯汀，我剛剛在看你的，是不是目前你和狗狗當封面的《君子》雜誌？謝謝。我有這本雜誌，對吧？當你說你剛才在看的時候，那是什麼意思？好吧，別擔心那個。
I mean, you're fucking enjoying it. I mean, you saw it. I was enjoying it. Which also means that it didn't even crack the spine. I enjoyed what I, the visual on the front. I know. Because Bateman can't fucking read. Yeah.
我是說，你他媽的在看。我是說，你看到了。我有在看。這也意味著你連書脊都沒折開。我欣賞我看到的，封面上的視覺效果。我知道。因為貝特曼他媽的不識字。對。
I, the great picture. I love the pictures. I love the pictures. And then I've opened it and then there were all these squiggling lines in blank. How did that, so when, how did the dog get on the cover? Was the dog just kind of like being annoying,
我，那張照片真棒。我愛那些照片。我喜歡這些照片。然後我打開它，裡面全是空白頁上的扭曲線條。那是怎麼回事，所以當，狗狗是怎麼上封面的？那隻狗是不是有點像，
sniffing around your feet while you're trying to take the picture and the photographer says, ah, fuck it, just put the dog in the shot. Well, she was on set with when we were doing the photo shoot. And then at the end of the day, it was a classic, like time to just do this trick all the time. No.
在你試圖拍照時在你的腳邊煩人地聞來聞去，然後攝影師說，啊，去他的，就把狗放進鏡頭裡吧？嗯，我們拍照時牠就在片場。然後到了那天結束時，這是一個經典時刻，就像「隨時來做這個把戲」一樣。不。
And the photographer just said, why don't we get a picture of you in Kumo? You know? And so I said, all right, great. And she jumped up there. And then- And what was the cover for? Was it a story on you or a project or?
攝影師只是說，我們為什麼不拍一張你和庫摩的照片呢？你知道嗎？所以我說，好吧，太棒了。牠就跳上去了。然後——那是為了什麼主題的封面？那是關於你的故事，還是一個專案？
It's a story ostensibly on me, but you know, I've been promoting Mosquito Coast, the show that just came out. Mosquito Coast now streaming on all Apple. A great show and worth your time, everybody. Worth your time. If you want to see Mosquito Coast starring Justin Thoreau now on Apple.
表面上是一個關於我的故事，但你知道的，我一直在宣傳《蚊子海岸》，那部剛上映的劇集。《蚊子海岸》現在正在Apple上熱播。一部很棒的劇，值得大家花時間看。值得大家花時間看。如果你想看由賈斯汀·瑟魯主演的《蚊子海岸》，現在就在Apple上線。
There we go. Can I steal that little loop in the movie? Yeah, dude. Because Will's got a voice. Him saying that is worth a while. He's got good pipes for what he does. Thank you. And now back to the show.
就是這樣。我可以借用電影裡的那個小循環片段嗎？可以啊，老兄。因為威爾很有嗓音。他說的那句話很值得。他做這行的嗓子真不錯。謝謝。現在回到節目。
I want to get back to the photo shoot. So it seems to me, I couldn't tell by the framing, but it looked like, because Kumo was taking up quite a bit of the shot, that your arms were bare, but you rarely wear sleeves anyway. I can't really tell what, were you topless before Kuma came into the shot?
我想回到拍照那件事。所以在我看來，我從構圖中看不出來，但看起來，因為庫摩佔了鏡頭很大一部分，你的手臂是光著的，不過你本來就很少穿袖子。我實在看不出來，在庫摩入鏡之前你是光著上身的嗎？
And if so- I was topless before. This is a great quest. This is a great area. I'm glad we're in this area. You being topless reminded me of a flight we once took together. Can you walk the audience through your sleeping?
如果是的話——我之前是光著上身的。這是一個很棒的問題。這是一個很棒的領域。我很高興我們在這個領域。你光著上身讓我想起了我們曾經一起坐過的一次航班。你能跟聽眾們講講你的睡覺習慣嗎？
Let me tell you. Let me tell you something. Let's have it. So to listener- Oh, I think I know that Jason told me this story. This is a story. So I got an email, listener, there's a thing called a publicist.
讓我告訴你。讓我告訴你一件事。聽著。所以對聽眾來說——哦，我想我知道傑森跟我講過這個故事。這是一個故事。所以我有一次收到一郵件，聽眾們，有一種東西叫做公關。
And sometimes when people are about to write untruths about you, they show you what they're about to write. And they said, you want to comment? You say, no, I don't want to comment. That's absurd. Then I got an email saying, the inquirer, something is going to run a story that you're a nudist
有時候當人們準備寫關於你的不實報導時，他們會把準備寫的內容拿給你看看。他們說，你想評論嗎？你說，不，我不想評論。這太荒謬了。然後我收到一封郵件說，《詢問報》之類的報紙要登一篇報導，說你是一個裸體主義者，
and that you sleep naked. You get naked on airplanes. And we thought it was hilarious. And I was kind of toying with the idea of writing back, like a sort of a joke comment, to comment on the story. Obviously we just ignored it. And then like a year later, we were hanging out
而且你裸睡。你在飛機上也會脫光衣服。我們覺得這 hilarious。我當時還在考慮回覆一封類似開玩笑的評論來對這篇報導做點評論。顯然我們最後直接無視了它。然後大約一年後，我們一起出去玩，
and you reminded me, you said, God, remember when we went to fucking London together and you got fucking naked on the plane? And I was like, no, I didn't get naked. And you said, yeah, you did. And we were leaving LAX. We were getting on a night flight, you know, big long 11 hour deal.
你提醒了我，你說，天啊，還記得我們一起去他媽的倫敦時你在飛機上脫光衣服嗎？我當時想，不，我沒有脫光。你說，不，你真的脫了。我們當時正離開洛杉磯國際機場。我們要坐夜間航班，你知道的，那種長達11小時的大航班。
And I do take my shirt off because I don't like to sleep in pictures. So then I assumed that I laid down. Hold on, that's outrageous. But it's a gym cabin. It's not very good. I don't care. It's a public space.
我確實把襯衫脫了，因為我不喜歡穿著衣服睡覺。所以我當時以為我躺下來了。等一下，這太離譜了。但那是商務艙。這不太好。我不在乎。這是公共空間。
I'm in a cubicle. We were in first class. No, no. I slide the door down. You're right on the aisle. Listen, no, listen. I mean, I'm a total knock around that. I don't always fly first class.
我在一個隔間裡。我們坐的是頭等艙。不，不。我把門拉下來。你就坐在走道旁。聽著，不，聽著。我是個徹底隨和的人。我不總是坐頭等艙。
First of all, this isn't a guy, I'm not humping it in 38J, okay? Exactly. I'm not putting my feet up on someone else's baby. He's in 2A because only a clown goes in the first row. Okay? So he's in 2A. But look, if you sleep with your shirt off
首先，這不是個，我不是在38J座位上擠著，好嗎？沒錯。我才沒有把腳放在別人的嬰兒身上。他在2A座位，因為只有小丑才會坐第一排。好嗎？所以他在2A。但聽著，如果你在家裡睡覺時不穿襯衫，
when you're at home, that doesn't mean that, hey, listen, this is just the way I sleep. When you're on a plane going across the Atlantic. This is Jason. This is Jason. So we get on the plane. We haven't even gotten off the tarmac.
那並不意味著，嘿，聽著，我就是這樣睡覺的。當你坐飛機飛越大西洋時。這是傑森。這是傑森。所以我們上了飛機。我們甚至還沒離開跑道。
He's already in the pajamas. They're comfortable, you know? Toothbrush in his mouth. He's got his slippers on. And it's just like you are at home. Yes. You recreate your home exactly when you're flying. Which is okay if it involves being clothed.
他已經換上睡衣了。那些很舒服，你知道嗎？嘴裡含著牙刷。他穿著拖鞋。這簡直就像你在家裡一樣。對。你坐飛機時完美地重現了你的家。如果這不包括光著身子的話，那倒還行。
Now, you sleep, I'm imagining naked. Usually. How much do you imagine it? Well, it depends if the Esquire magazine's nearby. It seems like it's an ongoing imagination, right? Do you still to this day take your top off when you go to bed on a plane? Yeah, because that's gross.
現在，你睡覺時，我猜是赤裸的。通常是。你想過這件事多少次？嗯，這取決於《君子》雜誌是不是就在附近。這聽起來像是個持續不斷的想像，對吧？你到今天搭飛機睡覺時還是會把上衣脫掉嗎？對，因為那樣很不衛生。
I do, but I have a blanket so I cover myself in the top. That comes off. But I'm like underneath everything. He's not on the shuttle from New York to DC with his shirt off. Well, whatever plane he's on. You know, that little tiny blanket will come off about 20 minutes into your sleep.
我會，但我有一條毯子，所以我用上衣把自己蓋住。那個會拿掉。但我差不多是在所有東西下面。他可不會光著上身坐從紐約到華盛頓的接駁機。好吧，不管他坐的是什麼飛機。你知道，那條小小的毯子在你睡了大概20分鐘後就會滑掉。
It's a duvet. He's in the first. Everyone's asleep on the plane. It's pitch black in there. He's on Emirates. He's on British Airways. Your body's touching the germy seat from somebody else. Your body is shaking.
那是個羽絨被。他在頭等艙。飛機上的每個人都在睡覺。裡面漆黑一片。他坐的是阿聯酋航空。他坐的是英國航空。你的身體正碰觸著別人留下的佈滿細菌的座位。你的身體在顫抖。
Next time I do this, I'm gonna take the blanket. I'm gonna cut a slit in the center of it. I'm just gonna wear it like I would make sense. That's exactly right. Now, wait, one time I flew from LA to London and also in first class and I didn't, we were so excited. I was with my friend Reina and we took Ambien
下次我再這麼做，我要拿那條毯子。我要在正中間剪一個縫。然後我就會像穿衣服一樣把它穿在身上，這樣就合理了。完全正確。現在，等一下，有一次我從洛杉磯飛倫敦，也是坐頭等艙，我沒有，我們太興奮了。我和我的朋友雷娜一起吃了安眠藥，
because we're like, we're gonna get on that clock real fast, right? I took Ambien and then that didn't work because we were so excited. Then I drank wine and I couldn't get to sleep, couldn't get to sleep. So while everybody's sleeping over the Atlantic Ocean, I went to each person in the cabin
因為我們想說，我們要快點調整時差，對吧？我吃了安眠藥，然後那不管用，因為我們太興奮了。接著我喝了酒，還是睡不著，根本睡不著。所以當大西洋上空的每個人都在睡覺時，我走到機艙裡的每個人身旁，
about two inches from their lips and I pretended to kiss each person. And I went, good night, good night, good night. So you handle your drugs pretty well. This is one of those stories where they arrest you when you land and it's like Sean Hayes who fucking loses his mind. I one time took like,
離他們的嘴唇大約兩英寸的距離，我假裝親吻了每個人。我還說，晚安，晚安，晚安。所以你對藥物的控制力還真好。這就是那種降落時會被逮捕的故事，就像西恩·海斯他媽的失控一樣。我有一次吃了，
I took like an Ambien and I was going on an overnight flight to Scandinavia and cause I don't wanna get too specific, you guys. And so I'm flying cause I want follow up questions. Where are you going? So I was going to Stockholm. Thanks for asking. So I'm flying and I take the Ambien
我有一次吃了一顆安眠藥，正準備搭乘夜間航班去斯堪地那維亞，因為我不想透露太多細節，夥計們。所以我搭飛機是因為我想要後續問題。你要去哪裡？所以我當時要去斯德哥爾摩。謝謝你問。所以我搭飛機，我一離開登機門就吃了安眠藥。
right as we pull away from the gate. We get on the tarmac and then there's like, obviously like a slow down on the tarmac. So I'm like, Jesus Christ. And I can't put my seat back yet. And I'm like, oh, what the fuck? We finally take off and my seat won't go back. I mean.
我們上了跑道，然後跑道上顯然有點交通堵塞。所以我心想，天哪。而且我還不能把座椅放倒。然後我想，哦，搞什麼鬼？我們終於起飛了，結果我的座椅放不倒。我是說。
Oh my God. Freaking. Can you imagine? So I try and I can't call my publicist cause I'm in the air and I can't call on my Hollywood elite support. I can't call my Hollywood elite support crew. What about your team?
哦天啊。嚇死人了。你能想像嗎？所以我試了又試，我不能打給我的公關，因為我在空中，而且我不能打給我的好萊塢菁英後援。我不能打給我的好萊塢菁英後援團隊。你的團隊呢？
And I finally have to get, no, I had them come in, I helped. We mechanically put the seat back, but I'm in that Ambien. I'm 45 minutes into an Ambien and I've never been more out of it in my life. It was the weirdest experience. What's the matter with you guys?
我最後只好，不，我叫他們進來，我幫忙了。我們用機械方式把座椅放倒，但我已經處於安眠藥的藥效中。我吃安眠藥已經45分鐘了，那是我這輩子最神智不清的時候。那是最奇怪的體驗。你們是怎麼回事？
Where do you get your Ambien? Do you cook it up and shoot it in the back of your knee or something? Like it's real easy to just push you to bed. I get it where everybody else gets it. It was the men's room at the Greyhound station, man. Oh, there's your problem. What are you talking about?
你們的安眠藥是從哪裡弄來的？你們是把它煮開然後注射到膝蓋後面還是怎樣？就像讓人入睡很容易一樣。我是從其他人那裡拿的。是在灰狗巴士站的男廁裡啦，老兄。哦，問題就在那裡。你在說什麼？
Anyway, Justin, thank you for being here. Justin, what's your current drug intake? What's your favorite right now? What are you enjoying? No? A cup of, a strong cup of coffee. There you go. Okay, my two favorite questions to ask,
不管怎樣，賈斯汀，謝謝你來到這裡。賈斯汀，你目前的藥物攝取量是多少？你現在最喜歡哪一種？你在享受什麼？沒有？一杯，一杯濃咖啡。那就對了。好吧，我最喜歡問的兩個問題，
on that line, what is the craziest drug you ever took and what was the reaction? And then I need a really funny, tragic stage, theater stage story. Oh my God, sorry, sorry. I'm sorry, Justin. We're just, those are my favorite questions. You got a kid here from a student newspaper
順著這個話題，你吃過最瘋狂的藥物是什麼？反應又是怎樣？然後我需要一個非常搞笑又悲慘的劇場舞台故事。哦天啊，對不起，對不起。我很抱歉，賈斯汀。我們只是，那些是我最喜歡的問題。你這裡來了一個學生報社的記者，
and we're fucking giving him a shot here. And then if you have an up-tempo song, we would love to hear that. And also, what's your favorite musical? Like, Sean, I told you earlier, shut up. I like hearing tragic theater stories. I'm trying to think of like, I mean, I'm sure I have good theater story.
而我們他媽的給了他一個機會。然後如果你有一首節奏明快的歌，我們很想聽聽看。還有，你最喜歡的音樂劇是什麼？就像，西恩，我之前告訴過你的，閉嘴。我喜歡聽悲慘的劇場故事。我正在努力想，我的意思是，我確信我有好的劇場故事。
I mean, I did, it was doing a production of Lute one time and have you ever tried to be a singer or a dancer? No, never tried to be a singer. Will you even sing in the shower or in your car when you're alone? You know what, you know what Justin does? Justin invented Sing For Real, which we've now done for years.
我的意思是，我确实做过，有一次在制作《Lute》的时候，你有没有尝试过当歌手或舞者？不，从来没有尝试过当歌手。你甚至会在洗澡时或独自开车时唱歌吗？你知道吗，你知道贾斯汀做了什么吗？贾斯汀发明了“大声唱出真我”，我们现在已经做了好几年了。
It's a great game. What is the greatest game? Wait, what is it? A song comes on the radio and the first time we did it, we were on vacation, Justin, you remember, and this like Rolling Stones, like Start Me Up or something came out and Justin just goes, he says to me, he goes,
你知道嗎，你知道賈斯汀做了什麼嗎？賈斯汀發明瞭「來真的唱歌」，我們現在已經玩了好多年了。這是一個很棒的遊戲。這是什麼最棒的遊戲？等一下，這是什麼？收音機裡播起了一首歌，我們第一次玩的時候是在度假，賈斯汀，你還記得，然後這首滾石樂隊的類似《Start Me Up》之類的歌放了出來，賈斯汀直接走過來，他對我說，他說，
Sing For Real. No, cause you were going like this, you were going like, stop me. You're kind of doing like the pussy for your version. No, you weren't doing it for real. And then I said, I said, don't fuck around, sing it for real. Like as if you were fucking auditioning
來真的唱歌。不，因為你當時是這樣，你當時是這樣，stop me。你當時有點在學那個娘娘腔的版本。不，你當時不是來真的。然後我說，我說，別鬧了，來真的唱。就像你正在為一輩子只有一次的試鏡機會進行試鏡一樣。
for the audition of a lifetime. And you can't cheat, you can't do a joke, you have to really sing it as if you think you're good. You have to go like, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, we got it. We got it.
而且你不能作弊，你不能開玩笑，你必須真的把它唱出來，就好像你覺得自己很會唱一樣。你必須唱得像：stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up, stop me up，我們懂了。我們懂了。
Right, like that. But you could go even realer than that. No, we won't need another take. It's so embarrassing. It's the most embarrassing that makes me laugh so hard. But it's for people who are just humming along to something and you go, stop it. Yes.
對，就像那樣。但你可以唱得更真一點。不，我們不需要再來一遍。這太尷尬了。這是最尷尬的，這讓我笑得喘不過氣。但這是針對那些只是跟著哼唱某首歌的人，然後你說，停下來。沒錯。
Who sings this song? Sing For Real. Sing it for real or don't sing it? I'm shocked at how bad a singer I am and how bad a dancer I am too. I'd like to see both. I'd like to see you dance. Oh, it's just horrendous.
這首歌是誰唱的？來真的唱歌。來真的唱，不然就別唱！我震驚於自己唱歌居然這麼難聽，跳舞也這麼爛。我很想見識一下這兩樣。我很想看你跳舞。哦，簡直慘不忍睹。
Justin, back to the first question. What's the weirdest drug you ever took and what was the reaction? The weirdest drug I ever took, I did once try to smoke that, because weirdly, I don't love smoking pot. It kind of makes me, or I can do like in mini, mini, mini doses.
賈斯汀，回到第一個問題。你吃過最奇怪的藥物是什麼？反應又是怎樣？我吃過最奇怪的藥物，我有一次試著抽那個，因為奇怪的是，我其實不太喜歡抽大麻。它會讓我，或者我只能抽微乎其微的劑量。
And someone had some of that stuff, you get it like a head shop or something that's basically bath salts and I took a hit of that and I thought I was, I'm even getting anxious just talking about it. It made me feel like I was slipping away and I did not like that feeling. What was the next question?
然後有人帶了那種東西，你在頭飾店之類的地方買得到的東西，基本上就是浴鹽，我抽了一口那個，然後我以為我，光是談論這件事我就開始焦慮了。它讓我感覺自己正在消逝，我非常討厭那種感覺。下一個問題是什麼？
Did you call anybody that you regret having called? God, that's who I call. I mean, in my head, I just dialed them up and up and get me out of here. Make this go away. Only time I ever pray is when I'm salting. When you were a kid, when you were a little kid, what made you want to be an actor?
你有打給任何讓你後悔打過的人嗎？天啊，這就是我打的對象。我是說，在我的腦海裡，我只是把它們撥出去又撥出去，把我弄這裡弄出去。讓這感覺消失吧。我唯一會祈禱的時候就是我在吃鹽的時候。你小時候，當你還是個小孩子的時候，是什麼讓你想要成為一名演員？
Who did you see? Was it the pain of your childhood? Was it all the real pain of your childhood? The not seeing of my parents. Was it the door slamming behind your dad? Exactly, I'm just gonna go get a beer. What is a lung beer? He'll be back any minute.
你看到了誰？是因為你童年的痛苦嗎？是因為你童年所有真實的痛苦嗎？那種看不到父母的痛苦。是因為你父親身後甩上的門嗎？沒錯，我只是要去買杯啤酒。什麼是肺啤酒？他隨時都會回來。
I swear to God, you're gonna walk in that door as he misses me. But what was the big draw to acting for you? Was it a lifelong thing or was it something that you kind of stumbled into in college? It wasn't, I mean, again, it wasn't, I went in college, I studied visual art, a language, and drama, but I did them as like double majors.
我發誓，你從那扇門走進去，他就會想念我。但對你來說，表演最大的吸引力是什麼？這是一輩子的事，還是你在大學時偶然涉足的事？這不是，我的意思是，再次強調，這不是，我上大學時，我主修視覺藝術、語言和戲劇，但我把它們當作雙主修來讀。
The visual art, sorry, was that drawing? Cause I don't know if you guys know this, but Justin's like an incredible artist. Oh really? Oh my God. That's very kind. In fact, he can tattoo the hell out of your kid if you want to have one.
视觉艺术，抱歉，那是画画吗？因为我不知道你们知不知道，但贾斯汀就像个不可思议的艺术家。哦，真的吗？天哪。太客气了。事实上，如果你想的话，他能在你孩子身上纹个痛快。
Oh my God. I have a great picture of him. Tell the story, tell the story. He takes a Sharpie to my... Well, no, they come over and they want tattooed because they know I can draw. But they don't ask for you to put... No, they ask for...
天哪。我有一张他的好照片。讲个故事，讲个故事。他拿记号笔在我……嗯，不，他们过来想要纹身，因为他们知道我会画画。但他们没有要求你把……不，他们要求……
But then you turn my eight year old, at the time, maybe six year old daughter around. I say, I'm gonna do a big bat on your back. And then she goes, great. And then I do a big, huge Wu-Tang Sip. In Sharpie. And then Jason goes, hey man, she's graduating sixth grade tomorrow.
但接着你让我当时八岁，可能六岁的女儿转过身去。我说，我要在你背上画一只大蝙蝠。然后她说，太棒了。接着我画了一个大大的武当帮标志。用记号笔。然后杰森说，嘿，老兄，她明天就要小学六年级毕业了。
I'm like, well, is she wearing a crop top? I mean, come on. I know. Give me a break. She wanted a tattoo. All right, so you're in college, you're studying visual arts and you think to yourself?
我说，好吧，她穿着露脐上装吗？我是说，拜托。我懂。饶了我吧。她想要个纹身。好吧，所以你在上大学，你学的是视觉艺术，然后你心里想的是什么？
And then moved to New York and I'm gonna try visual arts or acting. And I kind of tried both, you know? So I would audition and then I would get jobs, like doing like murals and t-shirts for clubs or bars. Anywhere where I could, I did a couple billboards. Did you have a tag crew? Yeah, I used to run with a pretty rough group of tangos.
然后搬到纽约，我要尝试视觉艺术或表演。我两种都尝试了，你知道吗？所以我去试镜，然后我能找到工作，比如为俱乐部或酒吧画壁画和T恤。任何只要我能做的，我还做过几个广告牌。你有涂鸦帮派吗？对，我以前跟一帮挺野的涂鸦分子混在一起。
What made you wanna go to New York though, is that what made you? It was that thing. That was the thing that I really wanted to do more than anything in the world. And it was, it's like, you know how some people just, when they're kids, they just go like, that's the place I'm gonna go
不过是什么让你想去纽约的，就是那个让你……就是那件事。那是比起世界上任何事我都更想做的事。这就好像，你知道有些人，当他们还是孩子的时候，就会觉得，那是我要去的地方，
and that's where I wanna be. That was it for me. Like every movie I saw, you know. It was always movies like Rocky or Flash Dance, which were both in Philly, by the way. But it was, but I thought in my brain, they were in New York. So I was like, that's where I wanna go.
那是我想待的地方。对就是我。就像我看过的每一部电影，你知道。总是像《洛奇》或《闪电舞》这样的电影，顺便说一句，这两部都在费城拍的。但它是，但在我的脑海里，它们在纽约。所以我当时想，那是我要去的地方。
I've always had that lust for Manhattan and I've never been able to live there. You've done stints there. Yeah, but I've never had a place there. You know, I've never had a key on my ring where I could like, I have clothes there and I have food in the refrigerator and, you know. Yeah, well, you know what?
我一直对曼哈顿有着那种渴望，但我从来没能在那里生活过。你在那待过一段时间。对，但我从来没在那里有个落脚处。你知道的，我钥匙串上从来没有一把钥匙，可以让我在那有衣服，冰箱里有食物，你知道的。对，好吧，你知道吗？
You don't have the stomach for it, man. Yeah. You don't have the stomach. You don't have the guts. It takes a particular kind of guy. It takes a certain kind of, you know. That's my favorite bit when Will's in LA and I call, or I'll always know where Will is
你没有那份魄力，老兄。是的。你没有那份魄力。你没有那个胆量。这需要某种特定类型的人。这需要某种特定的，你知道的。当威尔在洛杉矶时，这是我最喜欢的桥段，我会打电话，或者我总能知道威尔在哪里，
because I'll call, or he'll call me. And if he's speaking like this, he'll go, hello? Oh, boy. Then I know he's in New York. I'm like, oh, what are you doing, Will? And he's like, just kicking around, you know. I'm gonna go to Ms. Vazoul's house later in the night. I'm back in the neighborhood.
因为我会打电话，或者他会打电话给我。如果他用这种语气说话，他会说，喂？哦，天哪。那我就知道他在纽约。我会想，哦，威尔，你在干嘛呢？他会说，就到处闲逛，你知道的。我待会儿晚上要去瓦祖尔女士家。我又回到这片街区了。
And I'm like, yeah, I just turned a big pot of gravy over here, all right? I just turned a big pot. Remember when the neighborhood used to be the real neighborhood? I mean, we were knock around guys back in the day. Pubcap was first base. We played stick bowl.
然后我会说，是的，我刚在这儿搅了一大锅肉汁，好吧？我刚搅了一大锅。还记得以前这街区是个真正的街区吗？我是说，我们以前都是些四处闲晃的家伙。Pubcap是第一垒。我们玩棍球。
We stick a stick. We played stick bowl just till the show went down and it got too hot. We'd open up, we'd open up the fire. We'd open up the fire. It was all bathing. It was the best thing in the world. Choked right through it, you know?
我们用一根棍子。我们玩棍球一直玩到太阳下山，天气太热了。我们就打开消防栓。我们打开消防栓。全都在洗澡。那是世界上最棒的事。直接顶着水冲过去，你知道吗？
Choked right through it. It's the only way to cool off in that hot summer heat. But you don't want to cross Bronx Highway. And you feel the grime on the back of your neck, and then you hear the dinner bell ring, and you got to go. Yeah, I just smacked in the back of my head for Father Pazoul, because I was an altar boy. I was an altar boy.
直接顶着水冲过去。那是炎炎夏日里唯一的降温方式。但你不想穿过布朗克斯高速公路。你能感觉到脖子后面黏糊糊的灰尘，然后你听到晚餐的钟声响起，你就得走了。对，我被帕祖尔神父在脑后狠狠扇了一下，因为我曾是个辅祭。我曾是个辅祭。
I didn't say my no rules that morning or whatever it was. You know, I was an altar boy, but we were knock on. I was an altar boy, but we used to get into such trouble, but don't cross Monsignor Montgomery. Monsignor Montgomery. Monsignor Montgomery. OK, so wait a minute. We do hours.
那天早上我没背好清规戒律还是怎么的。你知道的，我曾是个辅祭，但我们以前常常惹上那么大的麻烦，不过别去惹蒙席蒙哥马利。蒙席蒙哥马利。蒙席蒙哥马利。好吧，等等。我们花了几个小时。
Thoreau and I would do hours of this, and then put on any. That would actually be the whole phone call, is it? You would call. The other one we used to do was the hangover one, which used to make me laugh. Will would call me up and go, and I would always answer like. It started because I would always answer like I was asleep. And it'd be like 4 p.m.
梭罗和我俩会花上几个小时搞这个，然后随便打给谁。这其实就是整个电话的内容，对吧？你会打电话。我们常玩的另一个是宿醉那个，以前总能把我逗笑。威尔会打电话给我，而我总是会用……这一切的开始是因为我接电话时总是装作睡着了。而且当时可能是下午4点。
It'd be like 4 p.m. and I go, oh. And he'd go, hey, man, it's Will. Are you away? Yeah, what time is it? Panic. By the way, the panic in his voice, then I'd go, what do you mean, it's 4 p.m. It's Monday.
可能已经是下午4点，然后我说，哦。他会说，嘿，老兄，我是威尔。你睡着了吗？对，几点了？恐慌。顺便说一句，他声音里的恐慌，然后我会说，你什么意思，下午4点。今天是星期一。
What do you mean? Monday. Monday. He started drinking again. What's going on? No, we're listening. We also used to do, Sean, I did this to you yesterday. We used to do like Justin pick up and go, hello.
什么意思？星期一。星期一。他又开始喝酒了。怎么回事？不，我们在听。我们还经常玩，肖恩，我昨天对你做过这个。我们以前常常像贾斯汀那样接起电话说，喂。
And I go, hey, Justin, I've got Will for you. And then I'd come on, and I'd go, hey, Justin, you go, hi, Will. I just lost him. Just lost him waiting for Justin to get back. And we'd be each other's assistants. Tracy, this is a Hollywood back and forth kind of thing. And listen, I'm so sorry. Listen, these guys laughing about there is fake assistants.
然后我说，嘿，贾斯汀，我帮你找了威尔。然后我切上线，说，嘿，贾斯汀，你会说，嗨，威尔。我刚把他弄丢了。刚把他弄丢了，正等着贾斯汀回来。我们互相充当对方的助理。特蕾西，这就是那种好莱坞式的你来我往。听着，我很抱歉。听着，这些家伙拿假助理开玩笑。
By the way, neither of us had assistants at the time, so that was the best part. That's really funny. So Justin. Sean, did you ever get to the bottom of his favorite color? Nail him down on this, Sean. I'm trying to steer it. Don't let him wiggle off.
顺便说一句，我们当时谁都没有助理，所以这才是最棒的部分。这太搞笑了。所以贾斯汀。肖恩，你到底有没有弄清他最喜欢的颜色是什么？死咬住这个不放，肖恩。我正试着把话题引过去。别让他给溜了。
I'm trying to steer it there. Exactly. I'm trying to steer your guests into some information, Will. Yeah, Will, where's your questions, goddammit? Instead of getting ragged on for being naked on planes with Jason. How can I? You spend all the time shaming him for being in good shape and sleeping nude on commercial airplanes.
我正试着把话题往那引。没错。我正试着从你的嘉宾那里套出点信息，威尔，是的，威尔，你的问题呢，该死的？总比因为在飞机上和杰森赤身裸体而被疯狂嘲笑强吧。我怎么能不呢？你花了一切时间嘲笑他身材保持得好，还在商业航班上光着身子睡觉。
I want to know, though, I want to know who those people, who the inspirations were, though, Justin, rather than just those movies that made you want to go to New York to be an actor. Like, were there specific actors or specific things that made you go, I want to do that. That looks super fun. Really?
不过我想知道，我想知道那些人是谁，那些启发你的人是谁，贾斯汀，而不是仅仅那些让你想去纽约当演员的电影。比如，有没有特定的演员或者特定的事情让你觉得，我想做那个。那看起来超级有趣。真的吗？
I mean, I think I love movies the same way that everyone loves movies. But there was, I mean, I didn't have one of those galvanizing moments of like, oh my god, I want to do that. Weirdly, actually, this is going to sound really odd. But I was very touched by, when I was a little, by a movie of the week that Henry Winkler did, where he played like a janitor or something
我是说，我觉得我对电影的热爱和所有人对电影的热爱是一样的。但确实有，我是说，我没有那种醍醐灌顶的时刻，觉得，天哪，我想做那个。说来奇怪，其实，这听起来可能真的很奇怪。但当我还是个小男孩的时候，亨利·温克勒演的一部每周电影深深触动了我，他在里面演了一个什么清洁工
in like a high school. And then he sort of, I can't really remember the plot exactly, but he basically would act. And that's when he would like, have like, that's when he was most himself. Well, but Justin, how do you feel about the insecurity, the thing that you can't, you can't count on being hired as an actor because you don't walk around with a diploma
在一所高中里之类的。然后他有点，我记不太清具体剧情了，但他基本上会去演。那就是他会，他会有那种，那就是他最像他自己的时候。好吧，但是贾斯汀，你对这种不安全感有什么看法，就是你不能，你不能指望被雇佣为演员，因为你身上没有带着医学院的文凭，因此……
from medical school and thus. It's the worst thing. I mean, early, I mean, I'm not going wood, I'm very lucky, as we all are in this chat. But, you know, the worst part about being an actor is, obviously you can't act at home. You can't just sit around and do it. You know, if you're a painter, you can sit home and paint.
这是最糟糕的事。我是说，早期，我是说，摸木头，我非常幸运，正如我们在这个聊天里的所有人一样。但是，你知道，当演员最糟糕的部分是，很显然你不能在家演戏。你不能就坐在那儿把这事干了。你知道的，如果你是个画家，你可以坐在家里画画。
You can play cello at home. You can't really sit home and act. Early on, you really need permission. Someone has to give you permission to do it. And that's the worst part about it. But I've always kind of always had like a secondary thing. So like when I was auditioning, it didn't mean as much, but it was like, I could forget about the audition
你可以在家里拉大提琴。你真的不能坐在家里演戏。早期的时候，你真的很需要得到许可。必须得有人给你许可让你去演。这就是最糟糕的部分。但我一直都有某种备选方案。所以当我试镜时，这并不意味着全部，但就好像，我可以忘掉试镜，
and I could go do, you know, mural work or I could go do something else. So I had another track to sort of go down, you know. So I wasn't constantly just pining after. I wasn't one of those people that went to auditions and then like thought about them all week and was waiting for the call. I'd do the audition and then I would forget about it.
然后我可以去做，你知道的，画壁画或者去做点别的。所以我有一条可以走的另一条路，你知道的。所以我不会一直都在苦苦期盼。我不是那种去试镜然后整整一周都在想这事、等着电话打来的人。我试镜完了就会把它忘掉。
I'd treat like a lottery ticket. That's what Jason would call. This is where Jason is going to step in with a sexy indifference. Healthy indifference. The last time Jason auditioned, by the way, when was the last time you auditioned for something? Seven, eight years old?
我会把它当成一张彩票。杰森就是这么叫的。杰森要带着性感冷漠登场了。健康的冷漠。顺便说一句，杰森上一次试镜是什么时候？你上次去为什么事试镜是什么时候？七、八岁的时候？
I think my last audition, I want to say my last audition was for the... Arrested. It might have been arrested. It might have been arrested. You auditioned for that? No, I think, oh, absolutely. In fact, I've got it on my computer.
我想我的最后一次试镜，我想说我的最后一次试镜是为了……《发展受阻》。可能是《发展受阻》。可能是《发展受阻》。你为那个试镜过？不，我想，哦，绝对有。事实上，我电脑里还有录像。
It's pretty, it's pretty... I love to sell it. We're gonna watch that. If you had a mural today, would, like, well, not if you had to, would you? Could you? What subject? And would you look for like, you know,
挺不错的，挺……我很乐意拿出来卖。我们要看看那个。如果你今天有一幅壁画要画，会，比如，不是说非得是你来，你会吗？你能吗？什么主题？你会去找，你知道的，
a wall somewhere to, or like, how does, how does all that... Like, you know, I've done a couple murals for like, people's like, kids' rooms or things like that. You know, it would be fun. I don't have time to do it, you know? What if you could like...
某个地方的墙，或者说，这到底是怎么……就像，你知道的，我给别人的房间比如儿童房之类的画过几幅壁画。那会挺有趣的。我没时间做这个，你知道的！如果你可以像……
Like some, like, gorilla sort of social commentary, like, in the middle of the night. I'm not into that. I don't want to do that anymore. You know, I don't, I mean, I never really was like, I would write a little graffiti, but I wouldn't like, I would never claim to be like, in a career graffiti scene or whatever.
比如某种游击式的社会评论，比如，在半夜。我对那个不感兴趣。我不想再那样做了。你知道，我并不，我是说，我从来没真正觉得，我会写一点涂鸦，但我不会，我绝不会宣称自己属于职业涂鸦圈什么的。
I did sort of like an animation style. You consider yourself on the same level as Banksy? Yeah. In a pinch. And take a minute. Don't answer too quickly. Yeah, because... Have you sold, have you sold works before?
我确实有点像动画风格。你觉得自己和班克西在一个水平线上吗？对。在紧要关头。花点时间想想。别回答得太快。对，因为……你卖过，你卖过作品吗？
Yeah, I've sold works. Couple pieces. Like, early, like, you know, little art shows and things really early on. But nothing like, you know, I don't think people are sitting on it like a hot stock or anything. Well, if you die soon, they will.
对，我卖过作品。几件作品。比如早期，你知道的，很早的时候参加过一些小型艺术展之类的。但没有什么，你知道的，我不认为人们会把它当成什么热门股票来囤积。如果你快死了，他们就会了。
Well, thanks. No, I'm just pointing out, man. Listen, JT, you also have a very, you have an extensive acting resume. And one of the things, I know you did Mulholland Drive, what was your relationship like with David Lynch? How did that sort of come about?
好吧，谢谢。不，我只是指出这一点，老兄。听着，JT，你也有非常，你有一份丰富的演艺履历。其中有一点，我知道你演过《穆赫兰道》，你和大卫·林奇的关系怎么样？这事是怎么促成的？
And what was, do you still have a relationship with him? Yeah, I mean, we text and chat on the phone every now and again. And when I'm in LA, I always try and see him. He's, you know, he's one of the best directors I've ever worked with. I mean, it sort of sounds, you know, like obvious because he's such a good director, but not because of just the great films he makes,
还有，你现在和他还有联系吗？对，我是说，我们每隔一段时间会发短信和电话聊天。当我在洛杉矶时，我总是尽量去见他。他，你知道的，他是我合作过的最好的导演之一。我是说，这听起来，你知道的，好像理所当然，因为他是个那么优秀的导演，不仅仅是因为他拍了那么多伟大的电影，
but he really is one of the kindest, most sort of explorative directors that you can possibly work with, you know, because he's giving you such incredible material and incredible leeway with what you can do. And I've been lucky enough to do two things with him, both very different, but he's just like a beautiful artist.
而是因为他真的是你所能合作的最善良、最具探索精神的导演之一，你知道的，因为他给了你如此不可思议的素材和不可思议的创作自由。我有幸和他合作过两次，两次都截然不同，但他简直就像一个美好的艺术家。
You ever tried any of that meditation that he's so big on? Yeah, I have tried it. I did the whole thing. What is that? I didn't have, it's TM, Transcendental Meditation. I didn't have the same experiences that I feel like a lot of people who still practice it do,
你尝试过他那么推崇的冥想吗？对，我尝试过。我整套都试过了。那是什么？我没有，那是超觉冥想（TM）。我的体验不像那些至今仍在练习的人所说的那样，
and probably it was because I was not a perfect practitioner. I can't figure out what the difference is between it and that space that you're at right before you fall asleep. Because it's a much more conscious way of, I mean, I'm sure you can fall asleep while meditating, but you're focused on a mantra, so you're repeating your mantra. So you're not really going to sleep,
可能原因是我不是个完美的练习者。我搞不懂它和你在入睡前处于的那个空间有什么区别。因为这是一种更有意识的方式，我是说，我确信你在冥想时也会睡着，但你专注于一个咒语，所以你在重复你的咒语。所以你并不是真的去睡觉，
but you're resting your brain. I will not wear sleeves. You're only supposed to- I will not wear sleeves. I will not wear sleeves. I will not wear sleeves. Certainly, it's a mantra. That was my mantra.
但你在让你的大脑休息。我绝不穿袖子衣服。你只需要——我绝不穿袖子衣服。我绝不穿袖子衣服。我绝不穿袖子衣服。当然，这是一个咒语。那是我的咒语。
So you're supposed to only think about the one thing, right? That it's a clarity and a singular thought that is supposed to be- I'm not an expert on this. I'm the wrong person to be asking these questions to, although I'm extremely spiritual and realized as a person. Wow. You are. You know, I spent a lot of time
所以你只需要去想那一件事，对吧？那种清晰感和一个单一的念头，应该是——我不是这方面的专家。找我问这些问题可就找错人了，尽管我作为一个极具灵性且大彻大悟的人。哇。你确实是。你知道的，我花了很多时间
just doing stuff for other people. Yeah. I just wanted to say that as a standalone. Yeah, okay, cool. I just wanted to get a quote, like I wanted one of those things like, on his podcast, actor Will Arnett claimed that he does a lot of stuff for others.
只是为别人做点事。对。我只是想把它当成一句独立的话说出来。好吧，酷。我只是想弄到一个引语，就像我想弄到那种，在演员威尔·阿奈特的播客里，他声称自己经常为别人做很多事。
Like that's a direct quote. Yeah, you can just pull that right out. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Sean, Will, you guys don't meditate at all, do you? Have you ever done that? I have. Will's meditating right now. I've done a little bit.
就像那是一句直接引语。对，你可以直接把它抽出来。对，对，对。肖恩，威尔，你们俩一点都不冥想，对吧？你们做过那个吗？我做过。威尔现在就在冥想。我做过一点。
Successfully? I've done a little bit. What does it feel like if you're successful, if it's working? I've done guided meditations just because I'm such a novice and I've only started within like the last six months. I like it.
成功了吗？我做过一点。如果成功了，如果它起作用了，那是什么感觉？我做过引导式冥想，纯粹是因为我是个超级新手，而且我大概也就是在过去六个月内才开始的。我挺喜欢的。
I find it very, it's a nice reset. Sometimes it's a great way to start the day. And I guess I didn't know anything about it before. So I thought it was like, how can it possibly, who gives a shit? And then I do it and I generally feel a little bit more present. Yeah, I don't know how people,
我发现它非常，这是一个很好的重置。有时这是开始新的一天的好方法。我想我以前对它一无所知。所以我当时想，这怎么可能管用，谁他妈在乎？然后我做了，我通常会觉得自己活在当下一点。对，我不知道人们怎么，
I, you know, you could, there's a bunch of apps, but you can set it to do like a minute or two minutes or five minutes or half hour. I don't know how people do it for like 20 minutes or half hour. But the goal is, and this is a question, the goal is to throw off stress, I think, you know. There's so much traffic in your head
我，你知道的，你可以，有很多应用程序，但你可以把它设置为一分钟、两分钟、五分钟或半小时。我不知道人们怎么能坚持做20分钟或半小时。但目标是——这是一个问题——目标是释放压力，我想，你知道的。你脑子里的车流太多了，
that you're looking to narrow things down and just have one car on the road. That's this mantra. Well, you'll notice if you ever, if you ever attempt it in a serious way, you'll, sometimes you'll be trying to do it. And then a million racing thoughts of what you have to do or things you're worried about, a little come in.
以至于你想要缩小范围，路上只有一辆车。那就是这个咒语。你会发现，如果你曾经，如果你曾经认真地尝试过，你会，有时你会试着去做。然后你必须要做的事情或你担心的各种纷乱思绪就会涌现出来。
And apparently that's not necessarily a bad thing. You're supposed to just let those thoughts go through and out like the weather, like a cloud that blows in. Yeah, you let them go. Like it's like, it's like thoughts are like a, I remember when somebody told me like to visualize like a leaf falling off a tree that lands in a stream. That's the thought and just let it kind of go.
显然这不一定是件坏事。你应该让这些思绪像天气一样穿过并离开，就像一朵飘进来的云。对，你让它们离开。这就好比，思绪就像是，我记得有人曾告诉我，去想象一片树叶从树上掉落，落入一条小溪中。那就是那个思绪，然后就让它顺其自然。
And then you let it go and you let that thought go. No, I got to pee. And then, but it just keeps like those thoughts that that's natural. And what's good about the guided meditation is for me anyway, is it's taught me to kind of, they go, it's okay. You're having, you're thinking about all these things, let that go, now focus back on your breathing or.
然后你放手，让那个思绪离开。不，我想尿尿。然后，但这会一直像那些思绪一样——那是很自然的。引导式冥想的好处是——对我而言——它教导我某种程度上，他们会说，没关系。你正在想所有这些事情，让它过去，现在重新把注意力集中在你的呼吸上，或者。
And then if you practice it for longer periods of time, then you get more relaxed. But well, when you meditate and you listen to those guided medics, you've inserted your resume in there, right? Yeah, no, I'm just reading your resume. It's an audio version of my reel. Right.
如果你练习的时间更长，你就会变得更放松。但是，威尔，当你冥想并听那些引导式冥想时，你其实把你的简历塞进去了，对吧？对，不，我只是在读你的简历。那是我的作品集的音频版。没错。
So it's just, I'm listening to my own reel. Are you just listening to your, your voiceover commercials that just mellows you out? Yeah. It's mainly like just a greatest sense of, you know, GMC and Reese's and old, old accounts. I'm not going to mention the old ones because they don't pay me anymore.
所以这只是，我在听我自己的商业配音，这能让你放松下来？对。主要也就是那种极其强烈的，你知道的，GMC、里斯和一些老账户。我不打算提那些老账户了，因为他们不再付钱给我了。
And now back to the show. Justin, you've, we had a guest on here fairly recently, the amazing, hilarious, gorgeous, wonderful, Amy Sedaris. And she was mentioning you and I didn't know that you guys. She tore you to shreds, dude. Let's be honest. Did she? You didn't listen to all of it.
现在回到节目中。贾斯汀，你，我们不久前请来了一位嘉宾，惊艳、搞笑、美艳、美妙绝伦的艾米·塞德丽丝。她提到了你，而我不知道你们俩。她把你撕成了碎片，老兄。说实话。是吗？你没听全吧。
She ripped you a fucking new one. I don't know if you felt the draft. Amy didn't listen to it. And then I said, you should listen to it. You were really fun on it. And then she goes, oh, and then I said, you know, after you got off, you know, they really praised you. It was really nice.
她把你骂得狗血淋头。我不知道你有没有感受到那股凉意。艾米没听那一期。然后我说，你应该听听。你在上面表现得真有趣。接着她说，哦，然后我说，你知道的，在你挂断之后，你知道，他们真的很称赞你。那真的很棒。
Like, I was like, you should at least listen to it for that because they went on and on about you after you clicked off. So I'm dying to listen to what happens after I. She was awesome. How did you meet her? And how did this friendship blossom? I was actually full circle coming,
我就像，你至少应该为了这个去听听，因为在你挂断之后，他们对你赞不绝口。所以我急于听听在我挂断之后发生了什么。她太棒了。你是怎么认识她的？这段友谊又是怎么开花结果的？我当时其实是在兜圈子，
doing that play shopping and fucking. And she used to work at Marion's, which was a restaurant just down the block on Bowery. Great sort of campy, like, but she was a waitress there. And she was at the time doing strangers with candy and waiting table. Oh my God. Like she would literally do like a day of strangers
去演那部话剧。而她曾在玛丽恩工作，那是鲍里街转角处的一家餐馆。那种很棒的富有戏剧色彩的，但她在那里当女服务员。当时她正在拍《踏上歧途》并兼职端盘子。天哪。她甚至会字面意义上拍一天的《踏上歧途》，
and then come back. But if she had like a black eye and a bloody nose, she would keep the makeup for the waiting table. And like people would, oh, what happened to your eye? And she'd go, oh, nothing, just the car door. I'm such a clutch. She would just do these bits, like, you know. That's so great.
然后回来上班。但如果她带着黑眼圈和流血的鼻子，她会保留着妆容去端盘子。人们会问，哦，你的眼睛怎么了？她会说，哦，没什么，只是车门撞的。我太笨手笨脚了。她就会演这些段子，你知道的。太棒了。
So we'd go there every night to eat after the show, me and Phil and a bunch of other people. And she would be there and she waited on us. And then we sort of became friends. Wow, I just love her to death. I just think she's amazing. She's fucking one of the best, most hilarious. You know, I find myself staring at that beautiful face,
所以演出结束后，我和菲尔还有其他一群人每天晚上都会去那里吃东西。她会在那儿，她招待了我们。然后我们就成了朋友。哇，我爱死她了。我觉得她太棒了。她他妈是最好、最搞笑的人之一。你知道，我发现自己正盯着那张美丽的脸，
that jawline of yours, and realize you've had that beard on for so long. What was it like when it finally came on? I mean, it's been on for like five years, right? Your beard? It's traumatic. I've had it like three or four years just because of work stuff. You find anything living under there when you're shaving off?
盯着你的那个下颌线，然后意识到你留这个胡子已经好久了。当它最终刮掉的时候是什么感觉？我是说，它已经留了五年了吧？你的胡子？这太痛苦了。我留了大概三四五年，因为工作需要。你刮胡子的时候发现下面有什么活物吗？
Well, it's not that I just shaved it off. It shaved it off. And I'm sorry to listener because you can't see, but I shaved it off and then was left with this. So I didn't get to shave the whole thing off. That would have been satisfying to leave this on your face. Your mustache is brutal. Yeah, the 40 pounder.
嗯，倒不是我刚刚刮掉它。我是把它刮了。我很抱歉听众朋友们看不到，但我把它刮了，然后只剩下了这个。所以我没有把整张脸都刮干净。如果能在脸留着这个一定很满足。你的小胡子太残暴了。对，那个40磅重的家伙。
And to know that it's a 40 pounder, I look, you know. Did your skin, did you get like, did you break out? Was your skin like, what the hell's going on? I broke out over here. I had little hotspots like a dog. Sure. I had a couple hotspots that I had to, you know, get some calming oils and to calm the skin.
而且知道它有40磅重，我看起来，你知道的。你的皮肤，你有没有长痘？你的皮肤是怎样的，就像，到底怎么回事？我这里长了痘。我像狗一样长了几个热点。当然。我身上有几个热点，我不得不，你知道的，弄点镇静精油来抚平皮肤。
We're recording this on a Saturday. What's your weekend look like up there? If I'm imagining you're not working until Monday, what the hell does Justin Thoreau do with his weekend upstate? I'm going to be, I'm nervous because I'm about to start a job. And so I'm going to be reviewing all my words
我们是在星期六录制这个。你们那儿的周末是什么样的？如果我想象你直到周星期一才开始工作，贾斯汀·塞洛克斯在州北部的周末到底都在干些什么？我将要，我很紧张，因为我马上要开始一份新工作。所以我打算温习我所有的台词
and breaking down my scripts. Practicing faces. Pract making faces in a mirror and putting a pebble in my shoe and getting a walk. Looking for that one prop. Yeah, that one thing. Give me the food, like the one, the apple, like to take the beat to do the long shoe.
并拆解我的剧本。练习表情。练习在镜子里做表情，在鞋里放块鹅卵石，然后去散步。寻找那个道具。对，那个东西。给我食物，比如那个，苹果，掌握好节奏来拍那场长途戏。
I'll probably Sunday tomorrow, Jason, I'll go into the prop shop and I'll cast my eyes around looking for, I don't know, a cane or a hat. Does G. Gordon-Liddy have a particular voice? I forget that you've been working on. And I'm not asking you to give it now, but have you been studying that? Yes, I have been.
我明天周日可能会，杰森，我要去道具店四处看看，寻找，我不知道，一根手杖或者一顶帽子。G·戈登·利迪有一种特殊的嗓音吗？我忘了你一直在研究这个。我不是让你现在就展现出来，但你一直在研究这个吗？是的，我一直在研究。
And do you feel confident about it? No, not yet. No? Are you doing it now? Are you working with a dialect coach? Am I doing it right now? Yeah, I'm working with a dialect coach. Who is it, Tony?
你对此感到有信心吗？不，还没有。没有？你现在在做吗？你在和方言教练合作吗？我正这样做吗？对，我在和一个方言教练合作。那是谁，托尼？
It's Tony, it's a thing. Is it Tony? Who is it, Reginald? Reginald, Reginald, we're both vaccines. My name is Ron. Is Monday your first day of acting? Monday's the first day. How's Woody hanging in there?
是托尼，就是那回事。是托尼吗？那是谁，雷金纳德？雷金纳德，雷金纳德，我们都是疫苗接种者。我叫罗恩。星期一是你第一天演戏吗？星期一是第一天。伍迪最近怎么样？
He's great. He's fantastic. What parts he playing? I just had dinner with him last night. He's playing Howard Hunt. He's great. I love that Woody Harrelson. So he's got free reign on an accent there,
他很好。他太棒了。他演什么角色？我昨天刚和他吃过晚餐。他演霍华德·亨特。他太棒了。我太喜欢那个伍迪·哈里森了。所以他在那里对口音有绝对的掌控权，
because I don't think anybody ever really heard him, except for- There's a little bit of footage on him, but yeah, he doesn't have the same pressures, because my guy ended up having a fucking radio show. A shadowy take note. Let me ask you something that is an actor, because we were talking about it before, about the schedule of an actor who does what you do,
因为我觉得除了——没有人真正听过他说话，除了——关于他有一些录像，但对，他没有同样的压力，因为我的家伙最后搞了一个他妈的广播节目。一个隐秘的潜台词。让我问你一个作为演员的问题，因为我们之前聊过，关于做你这种工作的演员的时间表，
which is like film to film, and it seems like you're traveling in a way. Is it hard? Do you mind that? I mean, because to me, the older I get, and I've talked with the guys at Nausium, about just the schedule of 14-hour days, being halfway across the country.
也就是一部接一部电影，而且看起来你一直在奔波。这很难吗？你在意吗？我是说，因为对我来说，年龄越大，而且我和大伙们无数次地谈过，关于14小时工作制的日程，身处大半个国家之外。
I don't know, I miss my home. I'd miss my bed too much. I'd miss my- Let's just hold on there for one second. Yeah. Sean, when you were doing Will and Grace, first of all, a multi-cam show is historically the cushiest, greatest schedule,
我不知道，我想念我的家。我会太想念我的床。我会太想念我的——我们先停一下。对。肖恩，当你在拍《威尔和格蕾丝》时，首先，多机位情景喜剧历来是最安逸、最棒的工作日程，特别是那部剧。你在《威尔和格蕾丝》任何给定的星期里工作的六个小时里。对。而且——
and specifically that one. Of the six hours you worked at any given week on Will and Grace. Yeah. And- Five of which were lunch hours. Five of which was just counting money. Five of those hours was just counting cash.
其中有五个小时是午休时间。其中五个小时纯粹是在数钱。这五个小时里有五个小时纯粹是在数现金。你——不，不，我——你知道吗，贾斯汀的生活，顺便说一句，我可以替贾斯汀回答这个问题。你见过那个化妆师吗？对。贾斯汀的生活很像阿尔伯特。
Did you- No, no, I- You know what, Justin's life, by the way, I can answer this kind of for Justin. Have you ever seen the dresser? Yeah. Justin's life is very much like Albert. He's very much like Albert Finney in the dresser.
他非常像《化妆师》里的阿尔伯特·芬尼。那是他的生活。如果你见过他——没错，不是汤姆·库尔特尼。不，汤姆·库尔特尼对他的阿尔伯特·芬尼。我们要停一下吗？来吧，该醒来穿衣服了。我们要停一下吗？我们要停一下吗？
That's his life. If you've ever seen him- Exactly, not Tom Courtney. No, and Tom the Tom Courtney, to his Albert Finney. Shall we make a stop? Come on, time to get wakey and put on your clothes. Shall we make a stop? Shall we make a stop?
停下，然后他就像，停下火车！让他们知道你来了。让他们知道你来了。所以，好吧，明天我们要稍微练习一下表情和声音。我们几点上床睡觉，以确保为星期一的工作得到充分的休息？九点左右给自己弄把安必恩。
Stop, and then he's like, stop the train! Let them know you're coming. Let them know you're coming. So, all right, so tomorrow we're gonna practice faces and voices just a little bit. And what time will we go to bed to make sure we're properly rested for Monday's work? Make a handful of ambient for myself at around nine o'clock.
这次在脚趾头之间注射。它可能会对你有不同的影响。每次开始做新东西时，你现在去上班时还会有第一天的紧张感吗？不是紧张，而是一种——就像蝴蝶在飞和——对，你当然会有。
Shoot up between your toes this time. It might affect you differently. Do you get first day jitters now when you're going to work and start at like, every time you start something new? It's not jitters, it's just kind of like- Like the butterflies and the- Yeah, you do, of course.
因为你还没演过这个角色。所以，如果这是一个完全未知的尝试，我很佩服那些对工作信心满满的人。我是说，我希望我也能那样。你听过吗？你有什么样的戏份？星期一是一场精彩过瘾的大戏，还是从轻松的开始？
Because you haven't done the character yet. So, if it's at all a swing, I love people that go into jobs totally confident. I mean, I wish I could do that. You ever heard so? What kind of scene do you have? Is it a big juicy scene on Monday or is it starting easy?
是一场精彩过瘾的大戏，是个好开端。我们实际上是按照大致的顺序在拍摄，这很好。这很罕见，肖恩，告诉听众们。所以，当你拍电影时，全都是关于日程、外景和演员，很多时候你是打乱顺序拍摄的，然后这就是剪辑要做的事。他们把所有东西在正确的地点重新组合在一起。
It's a big juicy, it's a good tip. We're actually shooting slightly in order, which is nice. Which is rare, Sean, tell the listener. So, when you shoot a film, it's all about the schedule and locations and actors, and you shoot it out of order a lot of times, and then that's what editing is. They put it all together in the right eight place.
杰森，还记得我以前给你的表演课吗，杰森？是的，天哪。我以前发给你的那些。一点不管用。几点，但说真的，告诉我什么，我对人们的睡眠模式很着迷。几点，因为你给我留下夜猫子的印象，我好像记得。
Jason, remember the acting lessons I used to give you, Jason? Yes, oh God. Those ones I used to send you. They did not work. What time, but really, tell me what, I'm fascinated by people's sleep patterns. What time, because you strike me as a night owl, I seem to remember.
正如你所知，我总是那个超级早就睡觉的人。我知道，六点。为了星期一的工作开始，你大概几点睡觉，我猜你是从一早开始？这里最棒的事是，我和伍迪在这个问题上达成了一致，那就是，我们在摄影棚里拍摄。所以，显然，没有光线依赖的问题。
I'm always the one that goes to bed super early, as you know. I know, six o'clock. What time will you be going to bed for start of work on, I imagine you start top of day? Here's the best thing, is that me and Woody are kind of aligned on this, which was, we're shooting in a stage. So, obviously, there's no light dependency issues.
所以他说，我们为什么不大概九点钟到那儿呢，我说，太棒了。所以，我想我们会在现场九点开始，这还不算，当有46次排练时，那就太残暴了。所以为了九点的通告，你打算几点睡觉？大概10点睡觉。快10点。
So, he was like, why don't we just get in there at like nine o'clock, and I'm like, great. So, I think we're gonna start it on set at nine, which is not a, it's really brutal when it's like four, 46 rehearsals. So, what time are you gonna go to bed for a nine a.m. call? Probably gonna bed at 10. 10 to 10.
你以为肖恩关于电影日程的问题就完了。我还没说完，阿奈特。我还没完。你还想探究他他妈几点，你几点要，这是你日程上的小睡。对，这是后续，这是后续。比之前早多少，我该怎么说？这对我很艰难。
You thought Sean's question about how the schedule of a movie was going. I'm not done yet, Arnett. I'm not done. And you want to get into what fucking time he's gonna, what time are you gonna, here's the snooze on your thing. Yeah, here's the follow-up, here's the follow-up. How much earlier than before, how do I say this? This is tough for me.
你几点起床？早多少，你九点得在现场。你是不是像杰森那样，有什么需要上班前维护的转盘棒球联盟专员事务？我喜欢——你在通告前给自己留多少时间？谢谢。你知道，就像在剧院里人们可以离开时，
When will you get up? How much earlier, you gotta be at set at nine. Are you a commissioner of any rotisserie baseball leagues that you need to service before work like Jason? I like to have- How much time before your call do you give yourself? Thank you. You know, like in a theater when people can leave,
当你正在演一出戏时，你会知道，肖恩和杰森对此一无所知。你能听到座位发出的咯吱咯吱的响声。因为人们在离开，因为他们讨厌这出戏。播客版的是什么？那对应的播客版本是什么？哦，对了。就是合上笔记本电脑的声音。
when you're doing a play, you would know, that Sean Jason would know nothing about it. That you can hear the seats going ch-chunk-chunk-chunk. As people leave, because they hate the place. What's the podcast equivalent? What's the podcast version of that? Oh, yeah. It's a laptop slam.
对，我们自己都听不见了。我只是想知道你的早晨常规是什么。你得起得超级早。就是这样，非常简单，杰森。我做一杯奶昔，我提前用菠菜、香蕉和一些浆果做一杯冰沙，我把它放进冰箱里。这就是我想知道的。这绝对是金子般的经验。
Yeah, we wouldn't be able to hear ourselves. I just want to know what your morning routine is. You got to get up super early. Here it is, really quickly, Jason. I make a shake, I pre-make a smoothie with spinach and bananas and some berries, I put that in the fridge. This is what I want to know. That's gold, right there.
好吧，那个放进冰箱。然后我还有一杯绿汁，我也把它放进冰箱。这一切都在晚上10点半之前搞定。然后我早上醒来，洗澡。我把东西装上搅拌机。我去，我把它倒进一个外带杯里。我把绿汁随身带着。你什么时候洗澡？
Okay, that goes into the fridge. Then I have a green juice that I also put in the fridge. This is all before 10.30 at night. Then I wake up in the morning, I shower. I put the thing on the blender. I go, I pour it into a to-go cup. I take my green juice with you. What do you shower?
你先洗身体还是先洗头发？哦，天哪。抱歉。用香皂还是用浴球和沐浴露。我先用护发素。然后你要把护发素冲洗干净。然后你想在护发素之后用肥皂洗掉身上的气味。
Do you do body or hair first? Oh, God. Sorry. Bar of soap or luffa and shower gel. I do the conditioner first. Then you want to rinse the conditioner out. Then you want to do soap after the conditioner to get out of your room.
所以现在你到了搅拌机前，拿到你的奶昔，把奶昔带去上班，诸如此类。直到午餐前你都不咀嚼、不吃任何东西吗？对，我差不多是这样。我尽量保持液体状态，直到我感到饿。一个午餐和晚餐主义者。保持液体。就是这样。
So now you're at the blender and you get your shake and you take your shake to work and everything. Do you not chew, eat anything until like lunch? Yeah, I kind of do. I try and keep it liquid until I get hungry. A lunch and dinner guy. Keep it liquid. That's it.
保持液体。对。你呢，杰森？除了在房间里备着一小包杏仁之外。你知道他妈的你知道是什么吗？只有12颗杏仁，一小杯该死的水，然后就疯狂渴望该死的甜食。我永远也不会成为塞洛克斯。
Keep it liquid. Yeah. What do you do, Jason? Aside from having a packet of almonds in your room. You know what the fuck you know what it is. It's just 12 almonds, a fucking thimble of water and then just pining after fucking sweets. I'll never be therothin'.
我是说，这家伙，该死的。我不知道你是怎么做到的。好吧，你一直都有——不，不。他以前吃东西像个该死的动物。他以前对糖上瘾。你想知道，这其实是，还记得粉红贝瑞（Pinkberry）刚出来的时候吗，威尔？
I mean, this guy, God damn it. I don't know how you do it. Well, have you always had a- No, no. He used to eat like a fucking animal. He used to be addicted to sugar. You want to know, this is what actually, remember when Pinkberry came out, Will?
记得。我们每天晚上都会在粉红贝瑞见面。你骑着自行车过来。这是威尔在追求健康。他会说，我们在粉红贝瑞见面吧。有个叫粉红贝瑞的新店，那是冷冻酸奶。
Yes. And we'd meet every night at the Pinkberry. You'd ride your bike over. This was Will on a health kick. He would get, he would, he'd say, let's meet at Pinkberry. There's this new thing called Pinkberry and it's frozen yogurt.
你可以吃所有你，你知道的。我会走过去，而他会说，你可以想吃多少就吃多少。它基本上是无糖的，零脂肪的。就像没有一样，就像什么都没有一样。所以我会走过去，我们去那个粉红贝瑞，布利克街上有一家粉红贝瑞，而威尔会拿，
You can get all you, you know. I'd go over there and he's like, you can eat whatever as much as you want. It's basically it's sugar-free, it's fat-free. It's like nothing, it's like nothing. And so I'd go over, we'd go to the pink, there was a pinkberry on Bleaker Street and Will would get,
就像肯德基全家桶那样的一个纸桶。他们会把它转着圈挤出来，大概有一英尺高。他会说，然后他就开始吃。他就会吃。与此同时，他的肚子他妈的正在爆炸。他拥有了，他拥有了，他拥有了。
it was like a Kentucky fried chicken tub, you know, like a bucket. And they would just swirl it like, and it would be about a foot high. And he'd be like, and he'd just eat it. And he'd just eat it. Meanwhile, his gut was fucking exploding. He's got it, he's got it, he's got it.
水，一直都是水。然后人们发现它其实并不是真正的酸奶。就像——我甚至不知道那是什么，但我的意思是它——但以前他就是那样。但在此之前，在那天之前的那些日子里，我们以前会去吃晚餐，然后我们每个人，我们会去，
The water and water all the time. And then it was revealed that it's not really yogurt. Like- I don't even know what it is, but I mean it was- But he used to do that. But also like before that, back in the day, in the day before that day, we used to go for dinner and then each one of us, we used to go
然后女服务员会问。你们想要点甜点吗？然后我们每个人都会说。我挺好的，但我想——我想他大概想吃圣代。圣代。就好像我们在为对方点单一样。因为我显然什么都不想要，但他想要。
and then the waitress would go. Do you guys want any dessert? And each of us would go. I'm fine, but I think- I think he probably wants the sundae. The sundae. And like, as if we're ordering for each other. Cause I don't want anything obviously, but he wants.
他想要，我知道他想要什么，因为他之前跟我说过——贾斯汀，这一切让我对过去感到无比怀念。你能不能搬回洛杉矶重新融入我们的生活？我会去的。我实际上会，我会在夏天结束时去那里工作一段时间。所以我希望我能见到你。
He wants, I know what he wants cause he was telling me before he- Justin, this is all making me very wistful for the past. Can you please move back out to Los Angeles and re-enter our lives? I'll be there. I'm actually going to be, I'll be out there working a little bit
这是你周一要开始的工作的一部分吗？对。我想我们会在洛杉矶杀青。哦，是吗？所以我希望我能在那里见到你。贾斯汀，我很想和你一起吃顿饭。
at the end of the summer. So I hope I get to see you. This is a part of the job you're starting on Monday? Yeah. We're going to finish in LA, I think. Oh, you are? So hopefully I'll be out there with you. Justin, I would love to have a meal with you.
对，走吧。我们能不能把——排好队，肖恩。他会照顾我，我们先。好吧，我要在纽约见他。我要在纽约见他。他会来我家里。来纽约吧，肖恩。
Yeah, let's go. Can we all put a- Wait your turn, Sean. Where he's going to take care of me and we'll first. Well, I'm going to see him in New York. I'm going to see him in New York. He's going to come out to the house. You come to New York, Sean.
他会来长岛，他会来我家。这家伙会带，这家伙会带上他、我和伍迪，我们要吃。哦，我们要开怀大笑。哦，我们会玩得很开心。哦，那些笑声。哦，那些笑声。
He's going to come out to Long Island, he's going to come out the house. The guy is going to bring, the guy is going to bring what he, me, him and what he, we're going to have. Oh, we're going to have laughs. Oh, we have a ball. Oh, the laughs. Oh, the laughs.
我们会哭，然后我们又会大笑。还有那么多其他的事要聊。我甚至不知道。你连一个关于你嘉宾的问题都没问。这不是真的。这他妈才不是真的。告诉我一个你做过功课的问题。我刚问了关于成为作家的事。
We'll cry and then we'll laugh again. There's so much else to get into. I don't even know. You haven't asked one question of your guest. That's not true. That's not fucking true. Tell me one question that you did any research on. I just asked the thing about becoming a writer.
我问了关于大卫·林奇作品履历的事。对。那给我们讲讲《钢铁侠2》吧。不，不，开玩笑归开玩笑，你参演了《钢铁侠2》。你和小罗伯特·唐尼在《热带惊雷》里变得非常铁。热带惊雷。我们拍那部电影拍得他妈的太开心了。我其实，我最初是通过你认识唐尼的。
I asked the thing about David Lynch resume. Yeah. So tell us about Iron Man 2. No, no, all jokes aside, you worked on Iron Man 2. You and Downey became really tight on Tropic. Tropic Thunder. We had such a fucking blast making that movie. And I kind of, I know Downey through you originally.
我问了关于大卫·林奇履历的事。对。所以跟我们聊聊《钢铁侠2》吧。不，不，开玩笑归开玩笑，你参与了《钢铁侠2》的制作。你和唐尼在拍《热带惊雷》时关系变得非常铁。我们在拍那部电影时玩得太他妈高兴了。而且我最初其实是通过你认识唐尼的。
And through that experience, he was like Iron Man 2, it's all you guy. Well, he, at the time, he thought, I mean, I'm sure he would say this. He was like, I don't, I think this movie is going to tank. Like Iron Man, talk about Iron Man. And we were on the set of Tropic Thunder, and he showed me the trailer. And I was like, dude, Iron Man was one of my favorite characters. And I said, you better buckle the fuck up, because this thing's going to be exploding, and you better have your seatbelts on.
通过那段经历，他当时就像是“《钢铁侠2》，全靠你们了”。好吧，他当时觉得——我是说，他肯定也会这么说——他当时觉得，我不知道，我觉得这电影要砸。就像《钢铁侠》那样，说到《钢铁侠》。我们当时在拍《热带惊雷》，他把预告片给我看了。我说，老兄，《钢铁侠》是我最喜欢的角色之一。我说，你最好系紧你妈的裤腰带，因为这东西要火了，你最好把安全带系好。
And he was like, I don't think so, I don't think. And then, of course, the rest is history. Knowing Downey, he's like, I don't even have a seatbelt to forget it. I cut him both out of the car. I cut him both out. So yeah, and then it exploded. And then so when that happened, he immediately was like, why don't you come and meet with the Marvel guy?
然后他说，我不这么觉得，我不觉得。然后，当然了，剩下的就是历史了。了解唐尼的人都知道，他会说，我连安全带都没有，算了吧。我把我们俩都从车里剪出来了。我把我们俩都剪出来了。所以，对，然后它就大火了。接着这事发生后，他立刻就说，你为什么不来和漫威的人见个面？
So I went over and met with them. And it's, it's, it is one of those things that it's, I'd love to take the credit, but you have to share the credit because Kevin Feige and Jeremy Lachem and Favreau and all those guys, it's absolutely a team effort in coming up with all the story. And they, Feige knows that property, knows all his properties so well. He's so, he's the biggest fan of his own. He's got from South of France.
于是我过去跟他们见了面。而且，这真的是那种……我很想把功劳都揽在自己身上，但你必须分享功劳，因为凯文·费奇、杰瑞米·拉克姆、费儒还有所有这些家伙，想出所有的故事绝对是团队合作的结果。而且，费奇对那个IP的了解，对所有IP的了解都太深了。他是他自己最大的粉丝。他从法国南部来的。
A lot of properties, different properties, different properties, different properties. Liz is very modestly, by the way. Yeah, Liz is very modestly, Jason. So take that into account. Yeah, Jason. And Sean sitting there in your mansion. We can hear the echo in your mansion, Sean. Okay.
很多IP，不同的IP，不同的IP，不同的IP。顺便说一句，莉兹非常谦虚。对，莉兹非常谦虚，杰森。所以把这一点考虑进去。对，杰森。肖恩正坐在你的大厦里。肖恩，我们能听到你大厦里的回声。好吧。
I don't even know where Scotty is. For like three days, haven't found him. I'm missing. She's unbelievable how out of touch you are. Check the mail. So what was that experience like though? Could once you get into that world, you're exposed to the, first of all, the fans of, of course, have only grown even more rabid.
我甚至不知道斯科蒂在哪。好像有三天了，没找到他。我失踪了。你对现实脱节到这种程度，真是难以置信。查收邮件。那么，那种体验到底是怎样的呢？一旦你进入那个世界，你就会接触到……首先，粉丝们当然变得更加狂热了。
But like, when you're in that kind of, for lack of a better term, machine of Marvel in that world, there's a lot of pressure. It's, there is, but, but at the same time, again, you know, Feige and Favreau at the time are such good shepherds of material that, you know, they're really the ones sort of at the steering wheel. And again, keep in mind, this was before Avengers. I mean, I was so blown away. I wrote Kevin an email after I saw, you know, the first Avengers.
但是，当你在那种——借用一个不太准确的词——漫威的机器和那个世界里时，压力很大。确实很大，但与此同时，话说回来，你知道的，当时的费奇和费儒是对剧本非常出色的引路人，你知道的，他们才是真正掌握方向盘的人。而且再次提醒，记住，这还是在《复仇者联盟》之前。我的意思是，我太震撼了。我看过……你知道的，第一部《复仇者联盟》之后，我给凯文发了一封邮件。
And I was like, it was like, he made Star Wars in reverse. It was like this, I couldn't believe how like, because, you know, it felt like we were sort of throwing in Easter eggs, you know, like, you know, Thor's hammer shows up in the coat of something, or, you know, and you think, where's this going? Or is this, are these just sort of pointless Easter eggs? And of course not. And there is a grand design to them.
我说，这就像，他反向拍了《星球大战》。这就像是，我简直不敢相信怎么会……因为，你知道的，感觉我们好像在扔一些复活节彩蛋，你知道的，比如说，雷神之锤出现在某个东西的斗篷里，或者，你知道的，你会想，这要走向何方？或者这只是些毫无意义的彩蛋吗？当然不是。它们有一个宏大的整体设计。
Super clever and super smart. So my follow up question is, how many t-shirts are you wearing right now? Hmm, two. I can't, yeah, I can see two. Because sometimes it's no, sometimes it's like really loose. Hold on, hold on, hold on one second, well, I got to take my, my cans off. Oh, listen, that's where he comes. Listener, he's standing up.
超级聪明，超级精明。所以我的后续问题是，你现在身上穿了几件T恤？嗯，两件。我不能……对，我能看到两件。因为有时候不是，有时候它真的很宽松。等等，等等，等一下，我得把我的……我的耳机摘下来。哦，听着，他来了。听众朋友们，他站起来了。
He's going to show us, we've got one t-shirt, the shirt's coming off. Oh, God, no. Now the sleeveless shirt underneath. Sleeveless t-shirt underneath, yes! That's what you wanted, wasn't it? There you go. Wait, what is this? Are you known for like sleeveless t-shirts?
他要给我们展示，我们看到一件T恤，T恤要脱掉了。哦，天哪，别。现在里面是无袖衬衫。里面的无袖T恤，对！这正是你想要的，对吧？给你。等等，这是什么？你以穿无袖T恤闻名吗？
Is that? I get so much fucking shit from Will for wearing these t-shirts. I got shoulders. By the way, you know I'm just jealous. Will, didn't you send him a gift one to a box of sleeves? No, I was going to, I was going to do it for a birthday. I was going to send him a box of sleeves. Why, Justin, do you wear sleeveless like every day or?
是这样吗？威尔因为我穿这些T恤没少给我气受。我有肩膀。顺便说一句，你知道我只是嫉妒。威尔，你没送过他一件礼物，一盒袖子吗？不，我本来要……我本来想在生日的时候送的。我本打算送他一盒袖子。为什么，贾斯汀，你几乎每天都穿无袖的吗？
In the summertime I do. Will, every time he would see me, he'd go, oh, okay, guys, can we all just- Take a moment. Take a moment and just, all right, be more in the loss of Justin's sleeves. All right, be Justin's sleeves. I did that once at like Thanksgiving, didn't I, when we were doing a toast? And we all did it, I just- Which just tells you that I was wearing a sleeveless t-shirt at Thanksgiving.
夏天的时候是的。威尔每次看到我，都会说，哦，好吧，伙计们，我们能不能都——花点时间。花点时间，然后，好吧，为贾斯汀失去的袖子默哀。好吧，当作贾斯汀的袖子。我有一次在感恩节这么干过，对吧，当我们举杯祝酒的时候？我们都这么做了，我只是——这只能说明我在感恩节那天穿了一件无袖T恤。
I know, you were. But I mean, listen, it's pure jealousy. I mean, the reply was always, and let's also take another moment to R.I.P., the first top four buttons of Will's shirt, because he's the shirt of his decollage. I'm wearing a crew neck today. I'm wearing a crew neck. I know you are wearing it. I'm a little disappointed.
我知道，你是。但我的意思是，听着，这纯粹是嫉妒。我的意思是，回应总是，让我们也为威尔衬衫的前四个纽扣默哀，因为他是他那件衣服的衣领……我今天穿的是圆领。我穿着圆领。我知道你穿着。我有点失望。
Normally we get something all the way down to the solar plexus. Hey, listen, I'm Euro that way. The other thing is I was going to say that for all my sort of making fun of your- A lease underwear. Well, my Bjorn Borg underwear, yeah. Oh, Bjorn Borg underwear. For all the shit, oh, in my Liverpool, in my Liverpool sweats. Oh, God.
通常我们能看到一直开到太阳神经丛的衣服。嘿，听着，我在这方面很欧洲。另一件我要说的事是，为了我所有对你……一件蕾丝内衣。好吧，我的比约恩·博格内衣，对。哦，比约恩·博格内衣。为了所有这些屁事，哦，在我的利物浦，在我的利物浦运动裤里。哦，天哪。
For all the making fun of you that I do, of course, it's all based out of pure jealousy, laying it down. Yeah, well, right. Justin, what a fucking delight. Thank you, bro. Brother, it's just whatever you- I miss you guys. I miss you too, man, so much.
为了我所有对你的取笑，当然，这一切都源于纯粹的嫉妒，坦白说。对，没错。贾斯汀，你太他妈讨人喜欢了。谢谢你，兄弟。兄弟，无论你……我想念你们。我也想念你们，老兄，非常想念。
But stop the madness. Let's move back out west, huh? Come on. Come on, come back east. The water's normal. There's plenty of production out here. More production here. Yeah, it might be true.
但是别发疯了。让我们搬回西部去，好吗？来吧。来吧，回到东部来。水温很正常。这里有大量的制作。这里制作更多。对，也许是真的。
You agree with that? Well, Justin, we'll go out for pizza when you get here. I can't wait. Can we really do that? Put together a dinner. Yeah, yeah, I'm coming east. He's going to come east. You might even see me with Will.
你同意吗？好吧，贾斯汀，等你到了这儿，我们一起去吃披萨。我迫不及待了。我们真的能那样做吗？组织一次晚餐。对，对，我要去东部。他要来东部。你甚至可能会看到我和威尔在一起。
He's going to come east. Oh, shit. So come on out. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. All right, I can't wait. I can't wait. I love you.
他要来东部。哦，操。所以来吧。对，对，对。对。好吧，我迫不及待了。我迫不及待了。我爱你。
I love you too, buddy. Miss you. Great hanging out with you, Shawn. Bye, guys. See you. Bye, pal. Have fun on Monday. I'm going to try.
我也爱你，老弟。想念你们。和肖恩你一起玩得很开心。拜拜，伙计们。再见。再见，老兄。周一玩得开心。我尽量。
Hey, say hi to Woody. Yeah. I will. Absolutely. I wanted to have him here. I was going to do that thing where I was going to surprise guests, you guys, and it would have been so much fun if you really do remember, please send my love. I just love him. I worked with him a lot. So I really absolutely will. I love Woody. I told him last night that I was doing it.
嘿，代我向伍迪问好。好。我会的。当然。我本来想把他带到这儿来的。我本打算搞个突击嘉宾什么的，给你们个惊喜，如果你们真的还记得的话，那会非常有趣，请替我转达我的爱。我太喜欢他了。我和他合作过很多次。所以我绝对会这么做的。我爱伍迪。我昨晚告诉他我要这么做了。
I'm going to get him on. Maybe I'll invite him on. Yeah, I can get into this podcast. Yeah, yeah. But can I just add myself? Yeah, yeah. Yes. I mean, you guys just add it.
我要把他请来。也许我会邀请他上节目。对，我可以加入这个播客。对，对。但是我可以把自己加进去吗？对，对。可以。我的意思是，你们直接加进去就行了。
That's the way it works this morning. Let's just add yourself. I'm doing it now too. Yeah, great. JT, you're the best. Thank you, man. Thanks for making time. I love you guys.
今天早上就是这么运作的。把自己加进去就行。我现在也在这么做。太棒了。JT，你是最棒的。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢你抽出时间。我爱你们。
I know it's a busy week and love you too. Love you, pal. All right, bye. Bye. Bye. The guy is just so damn fun, entertaining and fun. He needs to move back to west. I know.
我知道这是忙碌的一周，我也爱你们。爱你，老兄。好的，再见。拜。拜。这家伙太他妈有趣了，既有娱乐性又好玩。他需要搬回西部去。我知道。
He's a great guy. I don't know him. Like I said, as well as you guys, he's so down to earth and like somebody you just immediately want to get to know and hang out with. He's very real. He's such a, he's such a. His wit is so fast. He's so fast. He's so smart.
他是个好人。我不像你们那么了解他，他太脚踏实地了，就像那种你立刻就想去认识并和他一起消磨时光的人。他非常真实。他真的是个……他的机智太快了。他反应太快了。他太聪明了。
He's so funny and he's so sweet. He's such a sweet guy and he's been an unbelievable friend over the years and in every way. He's one of those guys. Super loyal. He's the guy you can call at any time. And if you're going through, it doesn't matter. He'd be the first guy there and Jason be the last. Well, you need bookends.
他太有趣了，而且人太好了。他是个大好人，这些年来在各方面都是个无可挑剔的朋友。他是那种人。超级忠诚。他是你可以随时打电话的人。如果你正在经历……没关系。他会是第一个到场的人，而杰森会是最后一个。好吧，你需要两头兼顾。
But I just wanted to let that settle with about JT for a second. I just want to connect with you guys. Yes. All right. Now you can just connect. Okay, good. No, good. Don't break eye contact.
但我只是想让大家对JT的这种评价沉淀一会儿。我只是想和你们连线。对。好了。现在你们可以连线了。好吧，很好。不，很好。不要移开视线。
Right. Yeah, there you are. Don't break eye contact. So usually you want to say how much you've really missed Justin in your life. Can we cue some music, Rob, Bennett? But I was just going to say, it's like, I want to make this contact. And if you need to wear glasses, like the ones that Jen wears, what are they called? Bye.
对。没错，你就在那儿。不要移开视线。所以通常你会想表达你有多么真正想念生活中的贾斯汀。我们能放点音乐吗，罗布，贝内特？但我刚才是想说，这就像，我想进行这种接触。如果你需要戴眼镜，就像詹戴的那种，叫什么来着？再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye, mom. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Hey, how you doing?
再见。再见。再见，妈妈。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。嘿，你好吗？
Hey, how you doing? Hey, you want to get a piece of pie later? Yeah, let's get a piece of pie later. We could, but my mom's making gravy later, so I can also get that. I'm stirring the gravy up. Ma, ma, I'm stirring the gravy. What do you want? Oh, I used to, ma.
嘿，你好吗？嘿，待会儿想去吃块派吗？行，待会儿去吃块派吧。我们可以去，但我妈待会儿要做肉汁，所以我也可以吃那个。我在搅拌肉汁呢。妈，妈，我在搅拌肉汁。你想干嘛？哦，我以前常那样，妈。
Ma's stirring the gravy, sounds like you. No, no, I'm going to go help old Mrs. Stanoots with the groceries, all right? She said Mrs. Stanoots doesn't even pick up the sausage. Yeah. I'm going to go. And put what the sausage is. No, I got to go get the sausage. I got to go do a rosary.
妈在搅拌肉汁，听起来真像你。不，不，我要去帮老斯塔努茨太太拿杂货，好吗？她说斯塔努茨太太连香肠都不拿。对。我要去了。然后把香肠放好。不，我得去拿香肠。我得去做个玫瑰经祈祷。
I got to get some rosaries. I got to see my novenas, you know. Yeah, I got to get my bees. I got a lot to pray about, like a lot to be grateful for. Yeah, and then the, God, God forbid, God forbid, God forbid. God forbid anything happens to you. Well, break my heart. Well, you guys do this in the fucking episode, please, Joe, you got it?
我得做点玫瑰经。我得去作九日敬礼，你知道的。对，我得拿我的珠子。我有很多要祈祷的事，比如有很多值得感恩的事。对，然后，上帝，上帝保佑，上帝保佑，上帝保佑。上帝保佑你千万别出什么事。那会让我心碎的。好吧，请在这一集里他妈的这么演吧，乔，你懂的？
There's no way that I would do that in the app or something. No, no, that's just for me and Will. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我绝不可能在应用程序里或者别的什么地方干这种事。不，不，那只是我和威尔的专利。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。